chairman major members of the committee
i want to thank you for the opportunity
uh to present on behalf of the insurance
department today
um
i also want to note that
amy duhain from our department uh should
be on the call as well
and she's our premium tax administrator
um
i'm a relatively new commissioner i've
only been uh with the state about ten
and a half months
and we have provided you all a copy of
our slide deck
the first five or six slides
deal generally with administration of
the department and i'm happy to go
through that
if some of your members are interested
in where our legislative regulatory
authority comes from and what the
we have nine new members on the
committee so i would suggest you go to
them perfect um so i think you can see
normally running the slides for me as i
as i chat um it'll only take me a few
minutes to go through these
you can see the mission of the
department there and the key the key uh
provision is to promote the public good
by ensuring the existence of a safe and
competitive insurance marketplace
through the development for enforcement
of new hampshire insurance laws
we're committed to doing that in an
new hampshire has a unique distinction
we were the first
insurance regulatory agency in the
united states
and our regulatory authority is codified
in rsa 400 through 420 n
and i think it's important here to just
note that a virtually all insurance is
regulated at the state level
and even though uh the regulation of
insurance is replicated uh 56 times
other authorities dc and the islands um
all of that authority
and administration
happens at each and every state level
and so with the exception of
some direction we get on things like the
affordable care act
almost everything is done at our state
level which provides us a tremendous
amount of autonomy here in new hampshire
to protect our new hampshire consumers
to ensure that products are appropriate
for our citizens
and that we have the flexibility to
to regulate those entities at the state
level
and it's a it's something that i'm very
proud of that as a nation we've
continued to
kind of protect that regulatory
we're charged with the enforcement of
all insurance laws for the state of new
hampshire and that includes collection
of premium taxes fees regulations of
insurance companies producers
consultants and insurance and adjusters
and when you think about um how big of a
group of people that is it's it's
shocking there are over 1200 insurance
companies that are licensed to sell a
product here in new hampshire uh some of
them are licensed to sell a variety
dozens or hundreds of products
and some have very unique products but
1200 separate companies have chosen to
to sell their products here in new
hampshire
and those products are sold almost
entirely through producers or agents and
new hampshire licenses 6 500 of our own
citizens as
insurance producers
and nearly 90 000 other uh producers
around the nation
who
who have reason to sell some product
here in the state and so they need to
maintain licenses with each state that
they they do that
in addition to the producers we also
we also license here in the state all
insurance adjusters and those are people
typically who are settling insurance
claims
generally they work for insurance
companies
uh but there are such things as public
adjusters or uh independent contractor
adjusters
and there are about 800 of those that
are resident adjusters and some 75 000
others that are out of state so in total
our licensing division here at the
department
handles almost 200 000 individual
licenses a year
we have a division here at the
department that reviews
all form and rate and so every insurance
company form that you get annually with
your different insurance products
we review to ensure because oftentimes
the insurance companies are national
players
and to ensure that those forms comply
with each and every provision that our
legislature has seen fit to require
uh for um standard uh coverages
and so each each form uh is reviewed
anytime a company develops a rating
structure for a determining premium
for a particular policy we have
actuaries here that review those uh
analysis to ensure that the rate
is both
fair that there's not too much upside
for the company in it but also that it
is that it provides enough rate for the
company to pay the projected claims
um
obviously that's that's very complicated
work and our team here does a phenomenal
job of that
because it's not just about a lowest
rate you want to ensure that these
companies will have sufficient reserves
to pay
pay the claims
and that leads us to our oversight roles
we have a financial examination and
analysis division
what they look at are companies doing
business in new hampshire do they have
adequate reserves are they reporting
their balance sheets appropriately are
they accounting for
a good data and bad debt and the value
of their investments appropriately so
that we know
how financially stable those companies
are
we have a division here that does market
conduct analysis and exams and those
generally come or come away uh come to
us in one of two ways we do some
proactive exams where we want to make we
want to test and make sure companies are
applying their rating structures
appropriately that they're paying claims
as required
that they're not being discriminatory in
their practices
and so when we do that proactively it's
just a review of the marketplace to to
make sure that
their products and their application of
their products is done in a fair manner
and then the other version of mark
analysis will do is if we notice claims
coming in or complaints coming in about
a particular company or
settlement practice we may do a targeted
exam at a company because we're
concerned with uh with those complaints
and we have a team here that um
actually two teams here one in life and
health and one in pnc
that
can review those
company procedures and policies
we also have a very small division here
that investigates and prosecutes
insurance fraud
um
and so
anybody can make a referral to our
department for a potential insurance
fraud typically those referrals will
come from
uh insurance companies they'll see a a
claim or a series of claims that raise
concerns
and they can refer them to us and in a
typical year about 240
insurance fraud claims are referred to
our team
our team will look at the facts maybe
we'll do
investigation
interview
witnesses
and in about 10 of those uh referrals
they find sufficient facts to refer that
case to the prosecutors for prosecution
uh and those can range anything from
uh you know completely
made up
insurance claims uh people claiming an
injury or a damage that never existed
um
sometimes we'll see somebody who who
chooses not to have insurance and gets
in an accident try to uh what we call
past post they try to buy insurance
after the accident
um
and uh and our team will do that
um it's important that as an industry
that somebody's watching out for bad
claims because of insurance fraud
affects everybody else
and the integrity of the system requires
it and our team does a very good job at
that
our department can and does hold
enforcement hearings when people violate
if we find that there is a intentional
violation of any of our insurance laws
we can hold a hearing
we have authority to
um
to
assess fines for violations of up to
twenty five hundred dollars per
violation uh depending on the uh the
extent of the violation and the
intention
uh and then annually we hold a series of
public hearings including a workers comp
a workers compensation premium rate
hearing that's a hearing that we hold
each year to talk about the status of
workers comp
and the projected rates for the
following year
and also we hold a hearing on health
cost drivers so that the industry can
get together and talk about things that
are impacting our um
our health insurance costs
one of the most important things we do
at the department is
we are
a consumer protection
vehicle and in a typical year our
department will have
just under 5 000
uh inquiries from consumers
and that could be anything it could be
you know what does actual cash value of
my policy mean or
um
you know how do i get on to the exchange
to
apply for an individual health insurance
plan
uh of those 5 000 or so inquiries 750 or
so um
are consumer complaints uh they're
complaining against an agent or a
company or
a billing practice
uh and we have a team here who will help
um
work with the consumers to determine
whether or not the there is a violation
of our insurance laws whether or not
there's a violation of our
settlement practices
or forms or notices
and we work through as a team to both
protect consumers and also work with the
companies to mediate and settle
potential claims before they ever happen
last year we tracked
just over a million dollars in
recoveries for consumers who had a
complaint filed with us and we have
tremendous
appreciation from those consumers we
often hear i didn't know that the
insurance department had these resources
for us and we're so thankful that new
hampshire does
um
and
uh
i think if you if you have uh
constituents through the through your
years as a representative
um who has an insurance question concern
uh feel free to reach out to me uh
directly
i'll i'll interface with your consumer
and then connect them with um
with our
consumer team but i'm happy to assist
you with those kind of constituent
concerns
um and actually probably now is a good
time any i'll give you all my um
personal cell phone which is
six
zero three
uh nine one eight
zero three 5 9
if i can figure out how to
email that all in this
in this mechanism after i'm done talking
i'll do that as well
and i'll give you my office direct dial
as well that's two seven one
um
i'll skip over the
collection of taxes because norma's
gonna handle that in detail
the department will also um participate
in in all legislative uh proposals that
relate to the department and we do we
try to do that in a way uh which isn't
advocating for against a particular bill
because we are keenly aware that the
policy decision
uh that addresses insurance regulation
is uh is virtually always yours
uh as as as the house representatives
and uh but that doesn't mean we're not
going to come in and just make you aware
of either
the consequences
intended or unintended of your bill or
what that might do to the insurance
marketplace that we have
and so you'll see the department come in
and say we have no position on a bill
and then
list off five or six concerns
we try to do that in a way that makes it
clear that we're not taking a policy
position on it sometimes it seems like
that
but we have experts here who have seen a
lot of these legislative proposals
before
uh we're happy to work with you on
legislative
initiatives that deal with insurance
ahead of time so that you're aware of
potential unintended consequences
but we're a resource to the legislature
um and i encourage you to use us right
if you have concerns with things related
to insurance
um i can assure you there is one of the
best experts in the state within this
building
and then finally i just want to talk
i've already i've already mentioned how
insurance is a state-based regulation
and we do it here in new hampshire well
and other states
and districts do a great job
but that doesn't mean there aren't
issues that that that are the same
across the nation and
new hampshire is a member of the
national association of insurance
commissioners
which is a voluntary group of all of the
56 insurance commissioners where we work
together to ensure that we're not
recreating the wheel in each state
so naic
in conjunction with all of the
commissioners and their staff across the
nation will often have model legislation
targeted at issues that we're all
dealing with
some of the naic
proposals ultimately become mandatory
because the naic
federal
financial regulatory process is managed
across the nation so it's consistent and
so on occasion we'll come in with
a draft legislation from them that
ultimately will need to maintain our
financial accreditation
but most of the time they're just
providing us resources that
best understand issues that we'll be
dealing with here in new hampshire that
potentially could have national impact
this is the point where i typically turn
this over to norma but if there are
questions about the department or the
administration i'd be happy to answer
them now
we're going to have plenty of time
within this hour to get through norma's
as well so if you do have questions i'd
i'd be glad to take them
i don't see any questions at this point
in time
perfect norm i'm going to uh put it over
to you and i want to say thank you for
making those slides move as my
okay so okay i think i've got it now
everybody can hear me is that all right
good deal
all right there were no sources where
does the money come from
the premium tax makes up approximately
87 percent
of the general fund revenue
that the insurance department collects
the other 18
13 is collected from the fees and
penalties
premium tax is level levied against all
admitted market licensed insurers
they that is composed of
new hampshire domiciled
and insurers that are domiciled in other
states but they're licensed in new
hampshire to sell
the types of companies that they're
licensed as is property and casualty
life accident health
and
your straight forward accident health
companies
there are also
entities that are simply registered in
the state that pay the taxes those are
risk retention groups as well as
purchasing groups
the licensed producers that have surplus
lines authority
on their producer license
sell the non-admitted
market
which is your lloyds
and
there are
other
companies that are u.s companies that
uh have
only surplus lines
uh excess
authority to
cover for policies and is also
independently procured and these are
policyholders that can go directly to
the non-admitted insurer and purchase
you'll find that more in the corporate
world that they'll have a risk manager
that can is knowledgeable and
understands
what their
needs are
and what they're purchasing
then the license and fees they can come
from
the license companies the registered
entities as well as the
the premium tax rates
were
1.25
for
property and casualty lines of business
and two percent for accident and health
fines business
there is a minimum annual premium tax of
now as of december 31st
we have
licensed insurance companies and 82
risk retention groups that are
registered and they're required to file
for the calendar year 2020 premium tax
which is due on a before march 15
2021.
now in accordance with the rsa 400 a 31
in 432
they pay the premium tax that
is due for calendar year 2020
less the estimated prepayment
that we received in march of 2020 as
well as the estimated prepayment for the
calendar year 2021
so basically when they are paying on
march
15th
they are
truing up what their calendar year for
the prior year is
and then they're paying the estimated
payment
for the full calendar year
the non-admitted market their tax rate
is
at three percent which that changed in
uh
july 1st of 2010
there are approximately as of december
31st
316 producers that reported
premium written for the calendar year
sometimes we have producers that
once in january they realized that they
had
written policies with new hampshire
risks
they'll file so on occasion we do have
more producers that actually have to
file the annual premium tax form for
surplus lines which is
coming due it's
technically uh
it's due february first because i just
realized
january 31st is a sunday so it's
not a business day so therefore it's the
following day that
their tax is due
the independently procured tax is taxed
at three percent four percent excuse me
four percent and that's due on march
first
of each year that they have a policy
in normal
yes
could you explain
more about the non-admitted market what
defines
the middle market
non-admitted market
they're not licensed
by the insurance new hampshire insurance
department
they are
um
they're only partially
required in the laws of new hampshire to
pay the taxes and to comply
with the certain other criteria they are
technically federally
um
regulated and
they they fall under
different statutes uh the most recent
one being the
dodd-frank wall street act
they they address some of the
non-admitted but as i said they are
there to provide
coverage for
the
people in companies that need something
that the admitted market
either
does not want to
uh cover or cannot cover
uh
in
you'll find that
they're
they
good percentage of them have to go to
uh lloyd's
to purchase
the coverage
again they
the coverages that i say they they're
just either in a very unique profession
that
the
admitted market
has not had a history or a trend so they
don't know
really how to price the policy
and
could you just give us an example of why
somebody would go to voids
because they can't buy the insurance
locally
was an example
if they would do that
there are some
medical professions that they want a uh
higher risk policy than what's covered
by the
medical
malpractice
policies that are sold
on the admitted market
there are
businesses
the
that
have litigation issues
that the admitted market
does not
uh
want to uh cover
in
there are
people that have some
very expensive antiques and different
items that
the admitted market does not
ordinarily cover
so the admitted market doesn't have
the history of how
much to price these items at whereas the
lloyds
in
other uh not admitted
uh companies that they do have
the ability to
price them the
thank you that's good
okay all right all right now on the next
graph here we have
actually a ten-year of the uh revenue
as
it came from the various
uh revenue sources
and just to
point out some of the
uh fluctuations here that
you see
where the
between fiscal year
15 to 16 16.
we had an increase
and that was the first full year of the
managed care organizations administering
the new hampshire health protection
program
and
they had approximately
493 million dollars in
uh premium written
so that's
what
drove that amount up and
then
in the fiscal year 16 we had
the
standard
medicare
aid medicaid
population that transitioned to the
uh
managed care organizations
so
there again we in fiscal year 16
the
premium was increased approximately 49
percent
or
736 million dollars
in fiscal year
there's a
decrease
because the
aggregate
okay
16 17 the
net aggregate pre taxable premium
increased four percent the actual
tax liability
was uh 1.2 million greater than than the
credit that was received now
there was also a
increase
in the
premium enterprise tax credit
of
1.5 million
and what ends up happening with the the
credit is that
it actually
impacts that estimated prepayment they
make so
the impact to the revenue collected
is
doubled so it impacts at 3 million
instead of the
just the million five
in fiscal year 18
that was the first year that
the insurance
transferred
premium tax of
11.7 million
to the
department of health and human services
for the health protection program fund
and then in fiscal year 19
the transfer was only
and now it's starting to level off
here
what determines the amount of the
transfer
it's based on the
premium tax that's collected
medicaid expansion piece
which
originally was
called the new hampshire protection
program
and now it's the
granite advantage
health
program but it's for the the expansion
of medicaid
and it's the premium tax that's
collected
thank you
so
on the next chart here of the net
premium tax again so you see in fiscal
year
there is still an increase because
the
this chart
shows the
premium tax written
in
it includes that expansion piece so
that's why this chart doesn't show a
decrease because that
transfer
i included
the premium written on on this chart so
the
actually the
health premium
between
fiscal year
14 and 15 increased by
and then in
fiscal year
okay
all right
this particular pie chart
shows the percentages
of the
premium written
net taxable premium written
by the
various
types of companies that
in the pre type of premium
that's written
in 2019 is the most recent
calendar year we have we don't receive
calendar year 2020 until march uh first
they're required to
report uh and as you can see
primarily because of the
carriers that are now
administering the
medic aid
percentage
is
almost equal to the property and
casualty
and remember the the health is taxed at
two percent
property and casualty
risk retention title in life are at
this is the non-admitted market and
the
taxes that we collect
from
them have increased over the years
uh there
is
one particular year that we did have
a exception that
uh created the
increase here there was a
single
policy sold on the non-admitted market
that uh
was that the tax was a million dollars
on that was a one-time policy and
and
won't be
i anticipated not to
happen again so but as you can see the
market the non-admitted market is
growing and
that's all right
she okay
the needs
of that that type of coverage is
increasing
now i just realized this morning that
this graft
i'm
missing some zeros on the end here then
and it should be in actual numbers
instead of
saying millions over here but
basically this this is showing
what is reported on the comprehensive
annual financial report
that the department of administrative
services
reproduces annually
as compared to what our plan was
and you can see that
we have
been very fortunate in the last few
years to
have
exceeded
so
uh what are the factors
that impact the insurance companies
general fund
revenues we have
the taxable premium written which is the
basis obviously
changes in the
premium tax rates
retaliatory taxes
premium tax credits mended returns
the re domestication of
the licensed companies
and then like i say as far as the the
volume
of fees that we collect primarily from
the licensing of producers adjusters
in the various entities
as well as the penalties that are
retaliatory taxes maybe we want to just
discuss that briefly basically
what happens is that
insurance companies have a unique
taxation structure
and
what
it
is is that
new hampshire has a tax rate of 1.25 on
property and casualty
now if a
massachusetts
company is licensed to do business in
new hampshire
and sells
property and casualty
they actually have to pay
2.28 percent premium tax to us
because
a new hampshire domestic
doing business in massachusetts
has to pay
2.28
to massachusetts
the intent there is that
the companies
are
leveling off the
tax burden
in this
should
or hopefully should be a consideration
when a company may decide to
re-domesticate
and
i don't know if the domestication
is
based on
the state
authority over those companies so at any
given point in time
a
new hampshire company
could file paperwork
and request to be redomiciled to
massachusetts
they file paperwork with new hampshire
insurance department as well as
massachusetts and they have to get
permission to do this re-domestication
you know there there may be you know
their business model has changed so
they're
uh
trying to consolidate some of their
businesses there are various reasons why
the companies would choose to
redomesticate
but the retaliatory provisions
are intended to
eliminate the
tax burden as being a factor
or a significant factor in that decision
making
now the
insurance market how it operates is the
business cycle has two phases
there's a soft market
and then there's a hard market
these cycles don't
necessarily coincide with
the
prevailing
economic
cycle
during a soft market there's excess
capacity
and the underwriting standards are low
and the price competitively high
in premiums decline
in
they may actually stay relatively flat
now rates for property and casualty
products
may be very slow to increase or may even
decrease
in a hard market
the capacity is a shortage in these
standards are more
stringent
in the competition for price is weak and
premium will increase so basically it's
a
supply and demand
if the demand goes up
then
the
capacity has to
be a
shortage will create a shortage because
the demand
and the current information that i have
from our actuaries on the property and
casualty market
is that
the
different markets
can flow through this cycle at different
rates
different lines of business
will have different demands the
commercial versus the personal
commercial tends to be more volatile
than personal
because of the regulations
that
take all comers in new hampshire
and then
since the great depression it was very
difficult to describe the position of
many insurance markets in the cycle
because of the economic recovery
although steady it's been very slow
there's also
tort reform and claim mitigations that
have also played a role in limiting the
volatility of commercial markets
so for example the medical professional
liability market in new hampshire has
been a soft market for many years
and that having finally been
hardening
well the workers comp market
looks to remain soft for at least the
near term
the effects on all markets of the kova
pandemic
remain to be seen but very early
indications suggest personal line
carriers retain more than enough capital
to delay or eliminate any customary rate
increases well commercial carriers are
revising rules to tighten language
around communicable disease
exclusions
okay
so
the
projections that we have are derived
from a blend of two methodologies
one the new hampshire insurance
department actuaries who receive the
company rate filings are in a position
to monitor any of the developments
in requested rate
making changes that will ultimately
become part of the premium charge for
the various lines of business
in addition they factor in current
general economic trends
that will ultimately affect the amount
of the premium tax
the
other
part two of that process is that the
insurance tax division
reviews annual statement information
the revenue trends from an accounting
and historic perspective
projections are developed for the
majority the major products categories
are based on trend analysis
and then the two methodologies are
merged together
so for calendar year fiscal year
2021 that we're currently in
we had originally
projected the
130.9 million dollars
in
128.2 million
based on
some of the
uh
reimbursements or
refunds that were going on
due to the pandemic in the
auto
market and then also
just the
general anticipated decrease in people
buying or renewing or businesses
renewing their policies
so
at currently
we actually
are
saying that uh
we're about 2 million as of december
31st 2020
the revenue focus
a report that the department of
administrative services producers showed
that we are ahead
by
2 million
for fiscal year but
that is primarily the licensing of
producers because
we obviously the
premium taxes
are due in march and that is where we're
getting
the
of our revenues so at this
time i'm still comfortable with a little
bit less
anticipated
revenue than what we had originally
so for fiscal year 2020
two in 2023
these are the projections that we
currently have as part of the agency's
submission
and
again
2022 is reflecting
a
you know continuation of the
decrease in the
the amount of
coverages and purchases
that are made
in
you know the transfer you know
generally it's the unknown impact of
what the kova pandemic is going to have
on people purchasing
their policies how it's going to affect
but we're anticipating in fiscal year
that
it will
be a recovery and the other thing that's
going to obviously impact is how much
federal
support is given to
the
states as well as the individuals
to help them
get back on
their feet on
the businesses as well as the
individuals
and last but not least
on this slide is the information for
contacting anyone in the insurance
department the general phone number or
fax machine
the consumer hotline is there
uh in i believe that
they're available at all hours or at
least they have a number that you can
leave information we also have a number
of email addresses here that
anyone can send
a email to or
a general request for information
so at any point in time
we're here to answer any questions and
help and assist in any way that we
excellent presentation
the insurance department along with
presentation relative to their revenue
and
deviate much from the numbers because
they've provided so much information
and clarity
the only thing is i hope that with the
covered 19 that things don't
get upset too much
thank you mr chairman
and yes i'm muted
i had two
questions which are generally around the
same kind of thing there are some things
you said today that i hadn't heard
before
and the first one was
on
the side you just showed showed the
problem that we have with a prepayment
on every year of the next year's funding
which means that we don't know what the
past one is which means that if
the past one was
higher than what we're going to get this
time
on
we lose double and if it's lower we gain
double which aggravates the cycles on
but you were saying something about this
being due to a
on to doubling the bet credit
change
and that confused me and then the other
one
well maybe maybe i could ask the other
one after you answer
okay on any credits whether it's the
business enterprise tax
or the there is another credit that's
allowed
for the life accident health guaranteed
fund
but
they're a dollar for dollar impact
to
the
tax liability
so if the tax liability
decreases
by
the million five
then
the
estimated prepayment
for the following year
which is based off of the tax liability
there's the relationship because that
that estimated
prepayment is based off of that tax
liability
that the estimated prepayment will also
thank you so this also affects the
amount of bt that we're getting
yes
so
some way you could estimate that too
so we've got it clear we
we actually have legislation in this
year so that i can
receive information
we can enter into a memorandum of
understanding with the department of
revenue so that they can provide us with
the
business enterprise tax that the
insurance companies have paid to them so
i will have that information a year
before
i currently
receive it
so i currently receive it when the tax
payments and tax reports are filed with
us
with the legislation i'll be able to get
that information a year in advance
hey thank you so
the d.r.a it's already been been being
incorporated in their estimates but it'd
be nice to know from our side the other
one is on you you mentioned that risk
retention and life is at 1.25
along with property and casualty i
always we we only changed property and
casualty when did we change risk
retention in life
well risk retention groups
sell property and casualty
the life was included the way that the
law was written it was
only the
accident in health the medical
that
remained at two percent
okay we've been fighting
for ten years we have others lined up to
ask questions and so just limit your
questions to two
so everybody gets an opportunity to ask
representative brandy
thank you uh norah um real quick so the
hhs transfer was that all part of the
negotiation that happened to get uh
medicaid expansion passed
as part of the ten percent that the
state has to pick up versus the ninety
percent that the feds are picking up
uh i remember that hospitals and and
insurance companies kind of said yeah
well
we'll we'll we'll basically pick up the
tab for the ten percent to get to ninety
percent is that correct
yes that that was part of the
legislation that was passed
when the federal
uh
portion started to decrease below the
hundred percent
right right thank you and the second
question is
is another example of a non-admitted
would that be someone like is a
professional piano player that wants to
insure his his fingers let's say and uh
other companies wouldn't touch it is
that
is that an example
yes
yes yes anything unique
yeah thank you um
so my question is about the
transfer
it's related to the granite advantage
health trust fund
and i'm wondering what kind of risk
there is that the transfer would would
be
uh
significantly greater than
what you have here for fiscal year 2022
and
something you can predict
if if the
transfer amount increases that would
only be reflecting because the premium
tax collected increased
so any increase to that
estimated amount
would mean that we collected more
premium tax
from that particular expansion
premium
good so that's a wash
thank you i'm looking at the revenue
estimates uh here and it says that
you're down by
0.2 is that because of the prepayment is
that or is what i
maybe i missed that
in your presentation if so i apologize
but i'm trying just to figure out this
should be
relatively steady every year and it has
been
um
are you is this in fiscal year 2021 that
you're
questioning
yes well again when we met with the
actuaries
to
update
the information
they were considering
what the impact of
the
refunds for the auto in
the unemployment
in
what all it
the
what was happening that kova 19 had
impacted
the people that uh in companies
so it was felt that
the
pr the premium tax would be less
in
again
it's it's really not a lot of the
premium tax amount but
again
because
even if you anticipate that the
premium tax collected is going to tax
liability will be decreased by a million
dollars
it also decreases that
prepayment for the following year by a
million dollars resulting in
okay
thank you for clarifying i i i
i didn't quite get that correctly in you
in your presentation thank you very much
you're welcome
representative
thank you mr chairman um
thank you norma for the presentation i
just have another clarification on that
same slide
um
130.9 million budgeted
128.2 million projected and you i
believe you made the statement that you
said you were comfortable
with that does that mean you're
comfortable with the projection of 128.2
million or the fact that
if it ends up being 128.2 million
i
i believe that that will be
the amount
that we actually collect
the fees have been
increasing and as i stated as of
december that we are ahead by two
million in the fees
uh
premium tax information
we really don't get
the
sufficient
detailed information prior to march 1st
so
i'm relying on what the actuaries
are telling me that you know
due to the
uh
impact of kova 19 that
the
premium tax would be less than what we
okay thank you
thank you
i do have another question and that is
on the premium tax uh how do we stand
normal compared to other states are we
in the middle
uh
i'm really not sure i don't have that
comparison
available but
the rate
we can get that for you uh chairman
major
okay then the final question is
the retaliatory tax
how big how much of a percentage is that
well it's broken down between the
retaliatory on the premium tax
amount
in the
premium
the
assessments
that other states have so
for instance
there are a number of different
assessments that massachusetts charges
new hampshire companies so
i have approximately
eight million that's collected
from
the
retaliatory on the various assessments
and fees that other states charge
on the premium tax rate itself
so that's that's a fair
fair amount
yes it's it's about 10 of the
okay
well again want to thank you for
a great presentation and answering the
questions of the committee and
okay thank you very much
thank you
all right the next one is from the
department of
going to have steve lavoie director of
administration and scott breyer
director of the road toll
and so
morning mr chair members of the
committee can everyone hear me okay
yes
very good uh my name is steve lavoy i'm
the director of administration for the
department of safety
with me today is scott breyer who is our
bureau chief of the road toll bureau and
we'll be presenting today
on the revenues that we collect here at
safety the vast majority of our revenue
collections have to do with the highway
fund we do also collect some general
fund revenues and those general fund
revenues are recorded in the other
general fund category so it's a small
portion of the very small portion of the
general fund so we'll spend a little bit
of time at the end um going over those
but the vast majority of our discussion
will be on highway fund and revenues and
what we're seeing um to hopefully
provide you with the information you
need to develop your estimates for for
the next budget okay and you're going to
be able to share your screen with us
all right are you seeing that yep
very good
so um
a little bit of an overview about the
department our mission is to make new
hampshire the safest state
oops to make new hampshire the safest
state in the nation with the highest
quality of life for all
and
that's our vision our mission is to
enhance safety security and quality of
life in new hampshire through
professional collaborative and
innovative services to all and we're
comprised of seven divisions plus
official commissioner
from a revenue collection standpoint the
division of administration and the
division of motor vehicles are the two
areas where we collect highway fund
revenues
some of our general fund revenues are
also collected through state state
overview of our revenue collections
we have significant highway fund
revenues usually 248 million in
unrestricted gross revenues as i
mentioned motor vehicles and admin
collect most of those and we'll go
through estimates as well as some
history on
the specific revenue sources including
road toll and the different motor
vehicle classifications and then for
highway fund as i mentioned we have a
small portion of uh that falls under the
other category only about nine million
um and those are collected in some some
key categories and we'll talk about each
of those that includes initial plate
fees penalty assessments
pistol permits and then some licensing
fees
to start we'll take a look at highway
fund revenues
each one of our slides as we work
through the presentation will be set out
in a very similar way um so we're going
to show the actual um
historical collections from 16 through
20 and then our projections are 20 for
21 22 and 23.
so this is the entire highway fund
revenue collection unrestricted gross
only um as a whole so this includes both
road toll as well as motor vehicle
revenue collections
and as you'll see um
from 16 to 20 uh we really are let's
pause and 20 from 16 to 19 there's been
a very slight increase each year usually
about one percent um
the the highway fund is uh a fund that
supports both the department of
transportation uh and also portions of
the department of safety uh including
state police
and um the rate of growth within with
revenues in the highway fund has not
um has not been able to fully support
the rate of growth and expenditures in
both of those areas so there's been
pressure on the fund as a whole for for
many years now um even a one percent
growth in the fund is not going to
support a two or three percent growth in
expenditures um which is a very modest
growth for for those operations but you
can see we did have growth from 16
through 19.
in fy 20 there was a decline uh due to
covid um we lost uh 10.8 million dollars
off of plant which is about 4.2 percent
less than we expected
uh if you recall hope started in march
so we really um we really had a strong
beginning year and so our our losses
weren't
as as big as they will be in 21 um
because in fy 21 we're experiencing
covet impacts throughout the whole year
so in 21
for the entire highway fund we're
looking to be 6.9 under plan which is a
for covet 19 impacts which will go into
more detail on each revenue source
road toll is really the main source that
was significantly impacted
as you'll see when we get to the motor
vehicle revenues
most
are in reasonably good shape there were
some small
reductions that we experienced but
overall motor vehicle revenues have been
stable it's road toll revenues based on
traffic volumes that um gasoline
consumption that have taken the hit
so at this point what i'm going to do is
i'm going to turn it over to scott
the road toll bureau administrator to
talk in detail about the road toll um
for those of you many of you know scott
already for those of you who might be
new to the committee
scott has been our our subject matter
expert on fuel tax in the state of new
hampshire for the last 20 years he's
been in his role for over 20 years now
and he's actually serving his second
term as the president of the
international fuel tax agreement
which which is a
fuel tax agreement that we have with
other states that we're a member of um
so he represents new hampshire um in a
very strong high role in that in that
national actually international group so
scott i'll turn it over to you now
okay
um
so road toll operations uh the road toll
is primarily statutory responsible for
collecting motor fuel taxes uh as most
people on the committee uh refer to as
the gas tax
in enforcing compliance with the motor
vehicle road toll law to its field audit
bureau
the road toll is not related to toll
booths on the turnpike system which is
operated by the department of
transportation
uh the road toll bureau administers
approximately 180 motor fuel distributor
licenses
1787 international fuel tax agreement
licenses and about 1900
international registration plan
registrants and there's approximately
200 uh 240
uh oil discharge pollution control
licenses this is uh these are the
licenses we collect our revenue on
behalf of the uh
department of environmental services
and um
the oil fund displacement board
so
this slide just kind of uh some of you
seen this before this is roll told this
is kind of show you where the point of
taxation is
uh new hampshire uses a distributed tax
uh model for motor fuel tax uh basically
uh fuel comes into the state to barge or
tank funds from
either transportation to trucks or barge
comes into a terminal facility
um and then it's delivered by truckload
um the point of taxation is when the
product gets dropped into the retail
station
prior to that uh no taxes are paid in
until it's put into the station so the
next slide please
so fact is impacting the estimates
uh changes in behavior to sponsor the
coven 19 pandemic caused energy demand
and supply claims in
the 2020.
the impact in future years remains
uncertain
so let's talk about price according to
triple a the average price per gallon in
new hampshire is about two dollars and
33 cents
this is down about
approximately 15 15 cents from last
year's average of two 2.48 cents per
gallon
prices have increased by about 17 and a
half cents
since december of 20 uh since this past
december
so the us energy
information administration forecast
motor gasoline prices to average about
240 a gallon in 2021 and 242 a gallon in
uh crude oil prices are average 53
dollars a barrel in both uh 2021 and
2022.
i'm going to talk a little bit how
weather affects realtor
dry summers and snowy winters help drive
tourism in new hampshire and result in
increased fuel consumption however with
the coven 19 restrictions lack of snow
and capacity limitations that the skiers
are putting a downward pressure on fuel
consumption
and then with the economy the real gross
domestic product
increased that annual rate of 33.4 in
the third quarter of 2020 in the second
quarter 20 the real
gross domestic product decreased by
31.4
companies may lock in cost savings
associated with remote working and
making these arrangements permanent
which if more people remote working
results in less community miles
and that will impact world totals
next slide steve
so this is kind of give you a picture of
uh unrestricted road toll revving
so
right now uh the gap price per gallon
for road toll fee is 22.2 cents a gallon
so fiscal year 20 we collected about
just shy of 120 million dollars in
revenues which was about 10.3 million
less than the 130 million that we
projected
fiscal year 21 we were projected to
collect
114.4 million in revenues which is 17.9
[Music]
or 13.5 percent less than the plan of
132.3 million
fiscal year 2223 projections assume that
full recovery in a pulse covered
environment will be around seven percent
of the pre-colbin levels during due to
the permanent reductions in commuting
that we anticipate from work at home
people that are not working at home
next slide please
this is just kind of a give a
kind of graph that shows what happened
uh during this past year because of
colby
uh original estimates uh some monthly
revenues would plateau at about five
percent of pre-covered collections and
the decline recovery rates over the last
several months have led us to revise our
uh expected plateau rate down to eight
percent
in fiscal year 22 the estimated world
poll revenue of 120 million assumes an
eight percent decline from pre-covered
fiscal 19 amounts in our fiscal year 23
estimated world total revenue of 121
million assumes a seven percent decline
from pre-colbin fiscal year 19 amounts
uh
so these uh i'm gonna turn the
presentation back over to steve but
before i do that is there any questions
thank you
a good scot good presentation so far
guys uh st uh scott
um how about the uh now this is
something near to uh uh representative
major's heart
uh the the continuing pressure of
efficient cars on the road is that been
factored in at all uh yes we always
factor that in um so as you know
as fuel might as the cars become more
efficient
uh and as people are switching over to
electric and other types of uh
alternative fuels that will have an
impact on road toll and that was uh that
was taken into consideration we were
coming up with these estimates okay
uh
you can go ahead there doesn't seem to
be any other questions
okay thank you
great thanks scott um and just for the
committee's benefit too um
you know scott and his team have done a
great job during copenhagen uh they have
they really modernized the tax
collection process prior to this years
ago um allowing for online collections
and even when we were forced to close
our offices for in-person um
appointments they were able to shift the
the little bit of collection that they
needed to do that's not online they were
able to shift that to a drop-off and
mail collection service and help people
over the phone uh so um all of the
reductions that you're seeing are
directly related to less vehicles on the
road less fuel being consumed um in in
no way does this represent any changes
in operations so scott and his team did
a great job keeping things moving during
uh during the uncertain times of covet
and again the the big piece
for the committee to consider is really
in 22 and 23
where that plateau mark will be we
believe it's going to be around the
eight or seven percent range um
it's it all depends upon um how much
volume on the roads we can expect to
recover to pre-covered levels and so
that that's the big unknown that's going
to be a challenge to project
unlike road toll which is based on
gallon consumption
dmv has been mostly insulated from from
the kobit 19 impacts
and there's there's a main reason why
one we've got uh minimal public
transportation options in new hampshire
we're a rural state and you really need
to have a vehicle to go about your
business to go to the grocery store
obtain goods and services um you don't
have other options like a major
metropolitan area
you're still going to need a driver
license to operate your vehicle
the tv did not waive any requirements
during the pandemic period they did
extend driver license renewals for a
six-month period but that extension
required you to reach out to the dmv and
actually collect the revenue at that
point in time um
it just if you needed to come in in
person for the eye exam or to get the
picture taken you could do that six
months later but there was no change in
revenue uh if they had made that change
we would have shifted revenue into
different periods um so because of that
they were able to to keep the operator
which is the driver licensing revenue
relatively stable um
and throughout the uh
throughout the pandemic um
one of the other benefits uh director
bilecki worked hard with her team to
make sure the dmv could stay open so
in new hampshire the dmv closed for two
days in march
and those two days were to change their
business model from in-person um
drop-in
appointments to
scheduled appointments and other states
including maine and vermont
they were closed for months and so the
entire dmv service was closed which
meant there was no revenue generation in
new hampshire we closed for two days
shifted the business model and were able
to continue to collect revenue because
of it so hats off to director bilecki
and her team for for making those
changes and really keeping us at a good
spot
um other factors impacting dmv fees um
we've seen vehicle sales
be impacted but they've really been
stronger than we've expected um
they've there's been a little bit of a
decline
a little bit of softness in vehicle
sales but
nothing as bad as we expected uh heading
into the pandemic
existing vehicles continue to be
inspected and registered so again those
requirements were not waived um
and some downward pressure on
registration and inspection but nothing
significant
um
one area that we did see reductions had
to do with traffic violations
so in plea by mail revenue
and also um court fines so those that
that went to court and and were paid we
saw reductions because there were left
hospitals on the road and less
violations that therefore being issued
so that is an area that we saw some
reduction
um and again changing the business model
was really key to to leveling off the
impact of covet dmv and so online
pop-off services allowed us to provide
service to the to the people of new
hampshire and continue to collect the
revenues
so motor vehicle registration revenue is
what we'll look at first
in fy 20
we collected 87.7 million which was
actually 2.6 million more than plan um
again if you remember fy20 only a
portion of that year had it was impacted
by um by the pandemic so we had a strong
first pass
which is why we did still see an
increase
uh in fy 21 we're projecting to collect
26.2 million in revenues which is about
one percent or 1.1 million more than
plan
um we still are seeing our our plan
numbers were were very conservative and
we're still seeing some some additional
increases not much
but some
so for now registration revenues appears
relatively strong
you know we're assuming a five percent
decrease because of cobit through the
rest of this year
and then we're assuming relatively flat
um into 22 and 23 just due to the
economic uncertainty of what's going to
happen in the next several years you
could take one approach and say we're
assuming everyone vaccinated and
overturned to normal
in the early fall
or um but we don't know that's for
certain and if variants are not
responding to the vaccine there might be
additional concerns so we felt a
conservative approach was the best
motor vehicle operator revenue
this is driver licenses
so driver licenses you'll see right off
the bat
fy 16 only 7.1 million fy 17 13 million
that change is due to a change in um in
law that creates a dip year where the
license renewal process
changed from four years to five years so
every five years we have a reduction in
um in licensing this is planned and
expected
unfortunately that reduction was planned
for in fy 21. so we essentially get a
double hit in fy 21 one due to covid and
the other due to
just a planned reduction in operator
revenues
so in fy 20 we collected 12.6 million
dollars which was about 726 000 less
than plan
and in 21 we're projecting to collect
8.8 million dollars which is about 300
000 more than plan
um
our projections are assuming a 40
decrease from the pre-covered levels of
the prior year which that 40 is
accounting for that dip year component
um and then based off of the dip year uh
and what we're seeing
it's about 23
increase each dip year so every five
years
the um we gained 23 thereabouts so
we're assuming then assuming that rate
is steady and continues
the dip year would resolve itself and
officially flatten
after 20 35 but until that point we have
to account for this every once in a
while
so as we move forward and we move out of
the dip year we really expect revenues
to return uh for driver license
operators to return to pre-covered
levels
because again the reasons we talked at
the beginning people need a license
they're required by law to have a
license to operate a motor vehicle in
new hampshire
and so
they'll they'll be coming forward for
their renewals as planned no real
concerns here
motor vehicle title revenue um again
this is an area that that really hasn't
has been somewhat insulated by covid19
in fy 20 we collected 9.5 million
dollars in revenues which is about 1.7
or 169 000 less than our plan
and in 21 we're projecting to collect
9.6 million which is about 200 000 or 2
percent less than plan
our remaining projections assume a 10
decrease through april and then a 5
increase in may and june
again assuming the economic recovery
does start to
show signs of of of more vehicle
transactions um and our our 22 and 23
projections really return us to our
pre-covet levels um looking at the
history from 16 to 19. um you know we
felt confident that uh we'll be
somewhere between the fy 18 and fy 19
revenue collection assuming that things
motor vehicle inspection revenue
this is a smaller area so we collect
about four million dollars here each
year
you can see in fy 20 we collected 4
million which was about 288 000 or 7.7
percent more than plan
in 21 we're projecting to collect 3.9
million and which is 300 000 uh more
than planned
um the inspection revenue this is the
fees collected from getting your motor
vehicle inspected it's three dollars and
25 cents for each each inspection
sticker uh there's also a two-year
station fee um inspection station fee
and those fees are are
represented in the um
in the dips that you can see each year
so you've got the peaks and valleys and
that's because of the two-year
inspection station uh revenue that comes
in so moving forward we expect this to
continue this revenue source to continue
this next slide
these are the what are known as the
miscellaneous fees for motor vehicles so
these fall under the miscellaneous
category
on on the revenue focus
so i've tried to color code these to
give you some uh some idea of what these
are so we'll start with the orange the
orange are the motor vehicle fines that
are collected by the judicial branch so
if you get a driver a violation and you
contest it
you do so in court and if the courts
reduce your fine or require you to pay
it
that's what these these amounts
represent so you can see there's been um
there's been a bit of a decline in these
revenues for some time
part of the decline in the past
have been changes to the uniform fine
schedule related to fees which allowed
some of some violations which used to be
must appear in court violations those
were allowed to be played by mail and so
those were some some of the higher speed
uh higher speed ticket violations and so
what we saw was an increase in plea by
mail in certain areas and a
corresponding decline here
so
in
fy 20
um
in fy 20 we collected 4.7 million
dollars um and in which which was less
percent 12 less than plan and fy 20
i'm sorry
5.6 million less than plan fy 21
projecting to collect 7.4 million
dollars
fy21 projecting to collect 4.3 million
dollars which is 640 000 or about 13
percent less than plan
our 22 and 23 projections are continuing
to show the slow recovery um kind of
tied in with the traffic assumptions we
have with roads
where again
less violations issued if there are less
vehicles on the road
um
i'm going to move
by mail next so plea by mail is a
revenue source that was added to the
fund
um
in in this past
in fy
20 the first year was added to the
highway funds in that budget cycle that
was originally
revenue that was
quasi restricted so it was it was
restricted for use by the department of
safety in certain areas
and then excess that was collected above
appropriations was deposited into the
general fund
in the 2021 budget
was moved to be entirely
deposited into the highway fund
uh which makes sense if you think of the
nexus of this rev it's it's primarily
traffic violence um the dmv processes
those using their staff and so um it
does make sense that this revenue source
would now be reflected here
so in f120 um
for plea by mail we collected 5.6
million dollars which was about 2.8
million less than plan of 8.4
and in fy 21 projecting to collect 7.4
million which is a million less than
plan of 8.4 we really did take a hit
from a plea by mail perspective due to
those traffic uh reductions at the
beginning of the pandemic and also due
to um decreased enforcement activities
just um people were we're all sorting
out how do we respond and provide
services in this new environment
that's all since been resolved and so
we are seeing an increase in our plea by
mail revenues
do expect that um we'll flee by mail
will start to recover in 2023
and start slowly moving
towards
moving forward
and then finally the green level here
these are the other miscellaneous motor
vehicle fees um
relatively small amount and um
not really significantly impacted uh by
coal thirds because they just fall into
the other the other category so we had
in fy 20 we collected 4.2 million about
950 000 more than planned and 21 were
3.5 million which is about uh 300 000 or
percent more than plan and we're going
to continue a slow recovery
um
so then moving on to um general funds
uh we
mentioned we do have a small amount of
funds that we collect um these again
fall under the other category within the
general fund as a whole so so this
amount that safety collects is
co-mingled within that full amount um i
do believe administrative services
reports that other amount out
to you as well but just our share there
um
and so what you can see here
the initial plate fee is um
is an area where we where we have seen a
decline in revenue um so
fy 20 5.1 million in fy 21
we're projecting 3.9 million um
and and this has to do with vanity
plates and it also has to do with um
your initial driver left
and so the decline that we're seeing
really has to do with the fact that in
the pandemic and throughout the summer
the state's driving license uh schools
weren't able to
operate at full capacity and they all
chose different ways about addressing
things but at the end of the day there
are less new drivers um getting their
licenses right now than there were um in
the year prior so there's some pent-up
demand in this area that we'll start to
see in some recovery in the coming years
but that's why we do have a reduction
here it's it's not the vanity plates
it's the initial driver license for new
drivers in the state
um the general fund uh penalty
assessment so we we don't have
significant
declines there
we also don't have significant declines
in in permits and licensing in fact in
permits and licensing this is an area
where we went from 491 000 in fy 20 up
to 590 000 in fy21
we do expect that to decline in 22 and
23.
the majority of this revenue that was
driving this increase had to do with
non-resident
pistol licenses
and that's at a hundred dollars each and
so there was an increase in gun sales
and there was also an increase from out
of state
individuals seeking a non-resident
license in new hampshire
we expect that to level off to
pre-pre-covet levels which has been
slowly phasing down
over time
because of the constitutional carry
changes that happen you know several
years ago
plumbers and gas fitters uh licensing
for those areas no real decline cova did
not impact the requirements to be
licensed to perform those services uh
and in fact a lot of people were getting
work done on their businesses and homes
um so there wasn't a decline in service
so so people stayed in business
and then just the other
categories nothing significant there
either
so the factors impacting general fund
estimates i talked a little bit about
these i i won't i won't repeat myself
but um
um initial plate and and initial license
and vanity plate fees so as we mentioned
it was the driver education schools uh
we expect it to recover in the next
couple of years penalty assessments so
this is when the court levies the
penalty of two dollars or two percent
and i have listed here where those go
the areas they support so 66.6 percent
supports the general fund and that's
what's represented in our estimates the
rest are the victims assistance fund and
the judicial branch who received the
information technology fund the judicial
branch who received the remainder
haven't really seen a significant impact
there
permits and licensing i mentioned the
resident
pistol license fees non-resident fees of
a hundred dollars
they have baseline revenue for detective
agencies and security agencies and
explosives handling that really didn't
change that wasn't really impacted by um
by covet 19 so we expect that to be to
to maintain uh but we do want expect
some fluctuation in the non-resident
licenses
and then finally the plumbers and gas
fitter fees with mechanical licensing
and inspection
as i mentioned
demand has has not declined in those
areas and so
businesses are doing well and people are
still maintaining their licenses
that is what we have for you today we
have also provided a
for the highway fund a separate document
just showing all the revenue sources
with the last since fy16 through our
projections um thought it might be
helpful for you as you're developing
your projections to have it all on on
one sheet um instead of having to work
through a presentation like this so
you should all have that if you if you
don't
we can we can certainly provide that for
you as well
and would be happy to take any questions
that you may have
okay thank you for your presentation uh
we can go directly to the
next presentation from the fish and game
commission and thanks again from the
department of state i actually had a i
actually had a question norman i didn't
see your hand raised sorry i thought it
was up and it wasn't sorry
are we running late are we running late
norm i think
we are
going with your question
oh okay
uh real quick two quickies um
why is the real id
refresh my memory why is the real id fee
60 and a regular operator license 50
dollars
is it because we have to deal with the
feds on this as more paperwork or
something
yeah it it that was a change that was
made in the last budget um and it does
have to do with the additional
documentation requirements that we have
um that we need to obtain and process to
issue the real id so there is an
incidental cost um to the department in
um in processing those and it was
determined that the additional fee would
account for that cost
okay thank you and the other quickie is
the 4.2 cent uh we we had to increase
the uh roto from 18 to 22.2
and where is the 4.2 going to these days
um i'll let scott uh jump in on that one
but that's a restricted
component that would not be reflected
here um so that's um
uh
i believe that was for
was that for betterment or red listed
bridges scott
i would probably the best one to answer
that would i refer that question to the
department of transportation but i do
know that it was
a big portion of that was to uh
pay for the bonds for completing uh
the
[Music]
i'd rather defer that to dot because he
would be much more knowledgeable on the
exact
uses of those uh at that particular
amounts
chris you want to jump in on that chris
represent major you had mentioned fish
and game was next actually d.o.t is on
at 11 o'clock so you have plenty of time
to continue to ask questions and to
scott breyer's point uh dot is the next
agency to speak to you so they should be
questions can i ask another question
that normal yes i thought i was
wondering i said geez my calendar had it
that we're
we have plenty of time here
um
and this is for the committee too that
uh
you know the beauty of the highway fund
this was a constitutional change that
happened years ago
that forces us to spend
uh rotol on highways and not and not be
stolen for to fund other things which is
a problem in a lot of other states
um
can anyone can any of you embellish on
that and how that's all worked out over
yes
steve can you take that
sure so um
yeah i i think i think restricting the
the road toll are you referring to the
portions of the road toll that are
restricted versus the portions that are
unrestricted
or the fact that the road toll itself
is only allowed to be used for the
highway fund it's necessarily allowed to
be used for the highway fund okay so uh
i think it's critical that the road toll
only be used for highway fund related
services um
what we're seeing is
even with the road toll and with this
restriction
there is not sufficient
revenues being collected within that
fund
fully support dot and to fully support
uh the department of safety and not
fully support the department of safety
but those areas of the department of
safety that are eligible for its use so
if
more
uses were allowed
the highway should likely be in even
worse shape
all right well i'll let it go with that
i
i know a lot of other states will
skim off the uh road toll or the gas tax
to
fund other things that which can't
happen in this state it's my
understanding because of the
constitutional change years ago
um but i'll let it go with that thank
you
hey steve can you put up that
um
the last chart which
you hadn't put up which shows all the
revenues
shows the un unrestricted gross highway
this one here representative no it has
oh the spreadsheet the spreadsheet
this one here
well
the last one in your uh
the
the separate page
right the separate page
uh
yes that one
would you briefly
um sure so
we start with our um
our full
collections so gasoline road toll line
this is the primary collections for the
for the gas tax for the road toll uh we
also do collect some revenues from
um
from fines and
audits we have an audit section in road
toll
to ensure really we're trying to ensure
voluntary compliance with with the road
toll but we do find things and we'll
issue um assessments and and penalty and
fines for unpaid road toll that was due
to the state uh and so we typically
collect you know anywhere from a hundred
and two to three 300 000 each year in
those areas
steve yeah to that a little
your scott
okay so basically in a nutshell road
toll fines is in that uh so somebody uh
is basically a the ten percent penalty
in uh the interest collected on people
uh we go out and do an audit if we found
somebody hadn't been paying us taxes
when we do an assessment there's a ten
percent penalty in uh
an interest rate right now it's around
five low over five percent interest on
uh
world totals that weren't paid on time
the other other world total revenues
that is exactly that is the after uh the
international fuel tax agreement uh all
the trucks uh any of the licensees have
to display a set of decals on both sides
of the trucks
that show that they're uh licensed for
ifta
uh that law enforcement can see
visually from the side of the road and
uh for a set of decals per per uh truck
is ten dollars and that that
100 a little over a hundred thousand
dollars is from the sale of those if the
decals
good
so then the next section has to do with
registration motor vehicle registrations
those are our state registrations um
which we which we have the graph that we
looked at earlier
and then we have two programs uh ucr and
irp and actually scott uh scott breyer
helps to administer both of these so um
scott do you wanna give a quick overview
of the of the two programs
yeah so
the way i look at you the uci new
hampshire base is the fees that actually
people uh the people that um
licensed in new hampshire they buy they
go in when they register they say
they're based in new hampshire
and then the other fees are uh
the other fees are what's collected
nationally and it's one of those
programs that was uh it's it's actually
a federal program that's administered by
similar to like if they're an irp but
it's unified carrier registration
and basically what happens is some
states collect uh for example new
hampshire's cat can't collect more than
like 2.29 million
so
what happens is everybody's guaranteed a
set allotment
so what happens is once we collect our
money um
anytime we collect more than like say
2.3 million we have to pay that money
back to the depository
so for example states like california
texas actually collect more revenue than
their what they call their cap is for
their program so all the extra money
goes into uh this other one
the other state collections and that's
allocated to all the states based on
whether they met their caps or not so
it's one of those programs where we're
guaranteed to get a set like 2.29
million a year
they add those two amounts together
scott why is the ucr new hampshire base
so much higher in 2020 actual than all
the others
it's more than twice the amount
oh um i think that was actually uh an
internal mistake here where uh
the money was coming in and uh the the
office had uh
you usually look at those two accounts
you add them together i think that was
just a mishap where they were putting
into the wrong receipt account
okay yeah it's because your total is
almost the same yeah so if you told yeah
if you look at the totals they're going
to be the two add the two together
they'll be pretty much the same
okay
so then moving on um motor vehicle
respiration
um we go into uh operators and so this
next line is our driver license revenue
um
and so again corresponds directly to the
chart that we had showed earlier
the next section has to do with
inspection station fees so these are
stickers and station fees um here you
can see the split
and really see the every other year
aspect of the station fee licenses
um and then the sticker revenue itself
uh next is certificate of title so again
this amount corresponds to to the chart
um that we looked at previously where
it's pretty
uh
pretty flat
very little change in that in that area
moving forward
and then we get into the other
miscellaneous fees category you'll see
plea by mail the new revenue source for
the highway fund that was added here
um you know plea by mail has been over 8
million in the past
knowing that because it wasn't part of
the highway fund then
but as we mentioned we expect to
do to achieve pre-covered levels um or
head towards pre-coped levels there
some small validation stamp deposit
revenue some miscellaneous fees the
overweight application fees this isn't
this is another area the overweight
vehicles um getting an application for
um for that transport relatively flat
and stable not impacted by covid we've
still had uh commercial vehicle um
activity in the state
license restorations uh fees associated
with uh if you lose your license in
order to have it recovered through
hearings um those are the same area
we've got similar amounts as in prior
years um a little bit of a decline based
on 19 but we're still expecting to
recover most of those
non-driver ids um we did see some a
decline in non-driver ids uh obviously
many people not driver id are typically
um are often older adults um but
we we
some people weren't comfortable coming
into the dmv if they needed a new a new
id
overweight vehicle fines this one's
really hard to
project because it's going to depend
upon um depend upon enforcement
activities and depend upon the safety of
the carriers that are out there on the
roads
and what their weight loads are like so
we usually project uh budget about 150
000 uh and if we get a little extra
there's a little bit of extra that we're
happy to receive
registration restorations
again some revenue here but not a huge
amount this is the next big one motor
vehicle fines judicial branch so we had
spoken about that earlier these are the
fees from
violations if you can test your ticket
you go to the courts
and the judge still says nope you must
pay those those are where those amounts
go um and so as the courts start ramping
back up to fully we expect those
sources will start recovering
as well uh and then finally the last
line is sale of vehicles um that is uh
any vehicles that we purchase with
highway funds um if we um
if we sell that vehicle light farm those
revenues are collected and deposited
back for many sales like that so
oftentimes we can sell a vehicle that's
used um
even if it's a cruiser we we take the we
take all of the markings off we paint it
so it's a single color we remove all the
law enforcement equipment and we may
still get uh fifteen hundred dollars two
thousand dollars for each one of the
cruisers even after they're beyond end
of life going through the the white farm
surplus process
and then your total here uh um
is at the bottom
and again this is unrestricted uh so
this would be any of those restricted
highway fund rep that go directly to
d.o.t that uh representative rami was
was speaking about
well thank you uh
represents uh almy has a question
thank you i'm way back up on
the motor vehicle registration section
most of that is on conformity with out
of state versus in-state based
on trucks do
we've lost a lot of truck registrations
to maine
uh even though they're based here
steve
yeah scott can you address that
so let me explain something about the
two programs irp is the international
registration plan
so how irp works is
the uh
it's kind of like if the
based on where the trucks go it's based
on where they travel so they pay at a
portion registration fee so even though
those trucks are registered in maine
portion plate in maine they have to uh
they have to allocate the portion of
time they're into new hampshire that has
to be denoted on the registration so
with if they're an irp it's just a
reallocation of the fees based on where
the trucks actually drive not where
they're actually registered does that
answer your question
so we don't really lose revenue on that
just based on where they the miles with
trucks actually drive
thank you but what about on ucr
so ucr what that is is uci new hampshire
based that's actually money that when
they registered they knew
they registered and they put on the
website that they were based in new
hampshire that money comes directly to
us
the ucr other states is money that was
collected by other states but because
for example in uh fiscal year 20
um
well that's a bad year because that was
the one that was a little messed up but
uh for example in fiscal year 19 we
collected about 900 000 and our cap was
like it's approximately a little lower
than 2.3 million
so what they do is you add those two
that that 2.8 million right there that's
that's all our money you add those two
together and that's all the state's
money it just just happened to be
collected outside our state and
because our cap is 2.3 million we get
allocated that money from the depository
so it's still our money and scott is it
is it fair to say that we um
in all likely
the cap is a is a ceiling for us
actually more revenue if the cap didn't
exist oh yeah if we didn't have the cash
for example if we didn't have exactly
steve if we didn't have the cap we would
only collect what whatever they paid to
our state
so each state has a cap
and yeah that's actually
did i just ask is that based off of the
irp results
well
let me put you this way basically any
vehicle any vehicle that operates uh in
the state one outside of new hampshire
in new hampshire has to have ucr
credentials
ifta
and irp
all trucks that operate like that those
three credentials
those trucks that operate interstate all
you all said
okay
i think it's very
complicated okay uh we'll have them back
again representative ames
before you do representatives uh when we
do our work sessions
uh this will probably elicit a lot of
questions and we'll have the department
back to be able to address these
uh representative ames
okay i thank you
this perhaps could be a question that
could be answered when they come back
but it's a it's a follow-up from
representative ramy's earlier question
and it's on the gasoline road toll and
uh
and i think scott you said that you do
factor in the move towards more
efficient or
totally electric vehicles and
but you didn't say how you factor that
in i think it would be helpful to us to
understand your
the assumptions that you're using as you
factor in what is undoubtedly
a move towards less gasoline
consumption per vehicle i guess a per
mile traveled
as we go forward into an era where
public policy is going to be pushing
yeah we can certainly um when it gets
time for the work sessions we could
certainly uh share with you
those assumptions and how we apply them
to the to the estimates
um it's at this point it's it's really
challenging because we're dealing with
the um
the traffic volume and gallon
consumption issues as well so it's it's
more of an art than a science for this
biennium but um to your point um
yeah we we can certainly explain you
know how we apply to our to our percent
increases
all right there's no other questions and
we are right on time and i'm glad we
have chris and others to keep me honest
here
so
thank you scott
and steve
thank you
all right
we will go right into the department of
transportation we have the deputy
commissioner christopher vosik mozart
and
marie mullen the director of finance so
christopher it's all yours
well good morning um mr chair members of
the committee
um my name is chris wasschuck deputy
commissioner with the department of
transportation and i believe uh marie
mullen is going to be joining me
um she's uh
director of finance and she has just
started sharing the screen
uh we probably have about uh 12 slides
that we would like to go through i'm
just going to provide a very brief
um
high level overview of the department
and then
marie's going to get into
um the unrestricted revenue projections
and the financial aspects of the
department uh hopefully we'll be able to
get through the presentation in about 20
minutes and then we'll have
10 minutes for any questions and answers
um
is that is that okay
mr chair that's fine okay great so marie
so um here's a mission and purpose you
know basically
it's the mission is simple and
straightforward transportation
excellence enhancing the quality of life
in the state
um in a couple key words that i want to
focus on
um transportation excellence the way we
view it it's it's fundamental to the
state's economic development and land
use
uh fundamentally enhancing the the
environment
preserving the unique character and
quality of life
we want to make sure that the
transportation system is safe secure
there's travel options for all our
residents and visitors
and the movement of goods um
is is efficient and the system is is
well maintained efficient and reliable
and again provide seamless interstate
into intra state connectivity so um that
is that is what we strive for
here's the way the department's
organized um in essence there's three
commissioners commissioner victoria
sheehan um
assistant commissioner and chief
engineer
bill cass and then myself as the as the
deputy commissioner
there's five divisions
project development division and
operation division report under
the assistant commissioner and chief
engineer
and then the divisions of finance policy
administration
and aeronautics rail and transit report
under um
myself
each division has a number of different
bureaus
i like for example project development
there are eight bureaus listed there
actually the seven bureaus and there's
project management
um
listed and
that division really formulates
um and develops
all the projects that are listed in a
10-year plan
that division is responsible for
executing those projects and delivering
those projects on the 10-year plan
schedule we have operations
those bureaus are responsible for
you know in essence maintaining and
operating the system that we have
in place
finance
is responsible for all the budgeting and
financial and in contractual as well as
auditing functions of the department
policy administration primarily human
resources and compliance
on communications and then we have
aeronautics rail and transit which are
in essence
associated with those three branches of
the transportation system so that's the
way we're structured
some key facts about the department
we have 1650 permanent employees
those are both
classified and unclassified
we have right now we have a very high
vacancy rate i think our vacancy rate is
upwards
over 15 percent which is very concerning
the pandemics certainly
uh required us to focus on limiting our
expenses and that was one area that um
was was identified to limit hiring um on
on the asset side we have a little over
bridges
um from a red list standpoint and the
red list in essence is uh
registered a deficient uh we have 125 on
the state side
on the municipal side there are almost
1700 municipal bridges
the municipal red list has 243 so you
can see it's a much higher percentage
of red less bridges on the municipal
side than the state side
that is very much a focus of the
department as well as the legislatures
all bridges are inspected every two
years
the red list bridges are inspected more
frequently i would say roughly every six
months to make sure that those bridges
are safe to carry the traffic
next slide
we have roughly
a little over 4
4 600 centerline miles of roadway that
we manage
there are additional 300
town maintained
miles within the urban compacts
we strive to pave a little over 10
percent of that
roughly and it's more of a target than
than a total
we try to target 550 cell line miles per
year that we pave and we've been able to
do that i believe over the last seven
years we've been able to
reach or exceed that target which has
really increased the quality and
condition of our road system
um
roughly seven years ago in 2014 68
percent of our roads were in good and
fair condition
um into uh 2019 82 percent of our roads
were in good and for their condition
so that focused effort is really paying
dividends
uh we maintain more than a hundred
thousand highway signs
strike more than 75 million feet of uh
striping
and then we have 440 traffic signals
that we also maintain um those are some
of our other major assets on the rail
side we have 195 miles of active
state-owned rail lines i believe we have
over 200 miles of inactive state-owned
rail lines as well that we oversee
25 publicly accessible airports and i
believe it's 11 not 12 local public
transit systems so
um that's kind of some of our key facts
of the department
and i'm going to turn it over to marie
marlin to talk about the financial
aspects
so marie
thank you chris um marie mullen as
representative major said i'm the
director of finance here at d.o.t
just a brief overview here of the
department's actual expenditures for
fiscal year 2020.
we we like to show our budget split
between operating and then the municipal
aid and construction
that blue part of the pie chart the
municipal aid and construction that's
primarily our 10-year plan which is
passed by the legislature
and begins later this year and during
the fy 22 session that goes through
um several steps through the gasset
process with governor and council
and then to the governor to the house
and to the senate all to weigh in on the
the 10 year plan project so that's
primarily that blue section
and then the orange section is the
department's operating
um section so
just to give you some context the
operating piece for fy 20 was about 38
percent of total expenditures and the
municipal aid in construction was 62
and
as you can see the department has is
comprised of various funding sources you
can see highway
is just over federal is the is the most
but we have a significant portion
of our budget is federally funded
and then we have the turnpike system
other we have some restricted revenues
and then the general fund is about one
percent
and that's primarily our aeronautics and
railroad bureaus
so just a little background on the
highway fund
[Music]
we we just like to to tell folks the
highway fund is not the d.o.t and d.o.t
is not the highway fund
as you just finished safety's
presentation safety is the department
which
collects the unrestricted revenue
related to the
road toll and registration fees
it's the primary source for
the operating budget for both
safety dot the judicial branch and uh
injustice all get
portions of the highway fund from the
revenues that are collected those
so next to look at
a little bit more of what dot is
responsible for the yellow highlighted
section are miscellaneous revenues in
the highway fund
that is what dot
has been
responsible for in collecting in the
past
the other revenues there are what safety
collects and they just presented that
information to you um previous to this
if we like to just show this historical
view of the highway fund so that you can
see some of the
um
one-time
uh short-term revenues that have that
were presented in the past to try to
shore up the highway fund but they were
all just temporary kind of fixes
so back in 2010 and 2011 there was a 30
registration surcharge and that was
repealed in 2012 so you can see those
significant declines
in revenue at that time
we had some other one time in the yellow
area related to retro turnpike toll
credits
those were
you know one-time toll credits that we
were able to go back and
and um collect
that um
is now you know has been gone for many
years we use toll credits now to match
our federal program because we're
required to do either a 10 or 20 match
on our federal projects
so we're using toll credits exclusively
to match that program
that's not revenue what it does is it
basically makes our projects a hundred
percent federal funds
so
this isn't revenue that we're collecting
um coming into the department
and then of course
some of you i'm sure are very familiar
with the i-95 i-95 sale of the
high-level bridge to the turnpike system
um so that was originally supposed to be
paid off over 20 years
and as you can see here it was paid off
over seven um so during that time those
revenues came into the highway fund from
the turnpike system
um to pay for that bridge um and that's
been fully paid off so those revenues
are now gone
the miscellaneous
is related to
federal indirect revenue that we receive
back in 2014 that became restricted
revenue and is applied to the
department's operating budget so um it's
just moved from unrestricted to
restricted um in that piece but then you
can see that the department's
you know miscellaneous revenue is a
small portion a couple hundred thousand
um a year
and i'll get into those projections in a
second but i just wanted to show you
some of that history
some of the one-time short-term
revenue items that have come in to try
to shore up the fund
temporarily
so here are dots miscellaneous revenue
projections um
these there are no changes to this so
the forecast and the budget is what was
originally submitted
um we anticipate to collect um you know
these small amounts of money for either
plant sales
junkyard licenses and some other small
items we have and then right-of-way
property sales
when we sell properties um they're
generally surplus related to the federal
program
so we're required
excuse me required by federal law
to restrict any revenue we receive from
those surplus lands that was federally
related
and it has to go back
towards federal projects
so what you see here is only the portion
that the state paid so if it was there
was a 10 or 20 percent match that we had
paid in highway funds in the past
then that revenue that portion that 10
or 20 percent would go here into the
highway fund is unrestricted revenue so
that's why
those sales are a smaller number because
it's really a very
finite
portion of those sales that go back into
the highway fund
and as we've moved to a hundred percent
federal uh using toll credits
um more of the current properties if
they get sold for surplus 100 of it goes
back to the federal program so
we don't those revenues wouldn't go back
so that is what i have on the highway
fund i don't know if there are any
questions i know there was a question in
the last um
safety's presentation on the 4.2 cents
so i just wanted to address that now for
folks
so
back in 2014
there was an additional 4.2 cents um
increase in the road toll
that was
designated for
bonding and to pay the debt service to
complete i-93
so there was a waterfall effect of that
so 12 goes to block grant
then
um debt service on i-93
then 6.8 million goes to towards state
aid bridges so that's the state aid
bridge program the municipal bridges
around the state
and then the remainder of any revenue
that comes in
goes towards the betterment program
and
some of you may remember
we entered into a tiffy alone back in
and we deferred the principal payments
for nine years so during this nine year
period we are using those funds um we we
have a covenant on the loan that
requires us to use those betterment
funds to for rural pavement and bridges
so chris had mentioned the improvement
in the system these this money that we
have been putting towards
um the paving and the bridges is why you
know has helped in why you're seeing
some of the
the benefit and the the
the increase in our in our
good good and fair payment condition
um unfortunately in
2025 the debt service on the tifia loan
uh begins so
all of those funds that were going
towards betterment will now be going
towards the principal and interest debt
service payments
um so we will see a significant decline
in what will be you know we'll be using
from those revenues on pavement and
bridges um and as it will be going
towards debt service so i hope that
answers um the representative's question
on the 4.2 cents and what's being used
on
i believe has a follow-up question
okay
representative bromley
representative romney you need to unmute
yeah i thought i did i'm sorry
uh thank you uh
so yeah my basic question is i i know
i-93 is is nearing uh and the
construction is nearing an end other
than the discussion of exit 4a still
exists
uh and is
so i
i was just wondering where the money
that was going to i-93 was going and i
think you you kind of explained it
um but that was the basis of my question
but what is going on with exit 4a while
we're at it
i'll let chris address that
so representative um you know thank you
for the question i-93 in essence has
been completed
the 200 million dollar tiffy alone that
we received has been expended um
if it you know it's nearly in full if
not in full
um
and
you know so that that money basically
now we're going to be paying the uh the
tipia debt service on interest only as
marie explained through 2025 and then
principal and interest beyond that
exit 4a is funded um it's fully funded
with federal aid and
in essence
that project initially was
planned to be a design build
type of procurement
um when the when the bids were open for
that design build procurement they were
um very high i think they were
over 30 percent higher than the
department's estimate so the department
has um decided to
pursue that project in a different
manner um
we're pursuing it
you know based on our typical design bid
build which will allow us
more control over
you know certain aspects of the design
and um the plan is to bring that project
in line with what the
dollars in the 10-year plan were
so
there will be a little delay in
construction i think that you know the
construction
we may be talking about um
several months to maybe six month delay
into construction staff from what the
original design build
um
plan was
um but
the first contract right now is planned
to
um go out in
on the spring of next year
okay thanks thank you chris good good
explanation appreciate it okay uh
representative army
thank you mr chairman
on
chris the
you'd said that we've made considerable
progress on the pavement i take it
that's starting in 25 we're going to
start to regress on that and also is
that going to affect municipal bridge
work
which i think we're still arguing about
yeah thank you for that question those
are those are good questions um
so yes we are going to see a decline in
the amount of pavement we're going to be
able to do
beginning in 2026.
we're trying to dedicate some additional
federal funds at that time
to the paving program
um to kind of
make up for for that loss however
the key
is that we have roughly i believe i'm
speaking off the top of my head
eleven hundred
uh miles of state roads that are not
eligible for federal aid
and that's where a lot of the a lot of
this tiffia money was uh was directed to
those type of roads
so
regardless of the amount of federal aid
we receive we will not be able to use
that on those roads and that's where
we're going to really see a decline
so that is a real concern for the
department once that once that happens
in 26.
um we've been making great gains um
on on the paving side with both the
tiffy pledged work as well as
um
the federal funded work that we have on
the system
relative to the state bridge program i
don't believe um
within this
next five to seven year time frame there
will be any impact to the
6.8 million pledge that we have
however um
i'd like to remind the committee that
that tiffy alone
sunsets in 2034
um as well as the 4.2 gas tax increase
sunsets at that time as well in
legislation so
um
we'll have a problem sometime in the
future
if it's not addressed on the municipal
all right i don't see any other hands
right so
you can continue
okay thank you very much
uh so now we'll um move to the turnpike
system um i know this is uh
you know not necessarily
um part of your purview and your
estimates but uh we wanted to to present
to you the information related to the
turnpike system especially related to
covid and the the traffic and
transaction changes that we've seen
so
the department is also responsible for
the turnpike system
which has three segments
is approximately 89 miles in length
and it is an enterprise fund so all the
turnpike revenue must be used on the
turnpike system it cannot be used on
highway state roads
general funds anything like that
[Music]
so
one thing about the turnpike system is
because we have revenue bonds it
requires the turnpike system to adhere
to the covenants
which include maintaining our existing
system before we can increase increased
capacity with large projects so you can
see here we're required with our revenue
to first pay operating and maintenance
costs
then debt service
then r r which is renewal and
replacement
on the on the system
once those things are taken care of and
are in you know fair and good condition
then we can spend additional revenue on
capital improvements
you know widenings and capacity
improvements and those type of things
so for fy20 we had about 110 million
transactions
that was a reduction of 11.6 percent
compared to fy19
our total revenue was 131 million which
was a reduction of 10.6 percent compared
to fy 19. so we did see
a significant reduction um in our
revenue and transactions related to fy20
and that's just from the three months of
covid um so that's not even a full year
impact
um here's some graphs and information on
our current traffic trends
so you can see
um the traffic on this 15-year trend
line you can see it just went like a
cliff in fy 20.
this chart over here has our fy 21
traffic by week
um so through january 17th overall year
to date we were down traffic by 19.5
percent
um and you can see we you know we had
back in september
you know we were seeing it come back a
little bit but then right after october
and um um
you know the october vacation weekend
there it jumped back up again and we
were seeing you know back in the 20
percent range
uh and even up to 30 around thanksgiving
so
um we still are not seeing that um
traffic coming back to the turnpike
system
um
it's primarily the commuting traffic and
the reduced vacation and pleasure travel
that's continuing to impact the
transactions our commercial traffic um
has come back and that is back to
pre-covered levels
but it's not enough obviously to to
impact
our revenue significantly
[Music]
so and then
here's a view of our historical turnpike
revenues
you can see we were seeing
you know modest increases
over the past five years and then again
an fy 20
here are projections um moving forward
on the turnpike fund
so
you can see our fy21 this is a revised
estimate we recently had a third party
expert
do revenue projections for us so that's
what is reflected here
they
are experts in the industry and have
done projections for many other turnpike
systems around the country including
maine and massachusetts and various
others so they're very familiar with the
trends and what's going on
um
so
you know they they're beginning to so
these projections show that you know
we're beginning they're gonna begin to
see increases for seasonal and
vacationers over time over the next
three years but it assumes we continue
to see reduced traffic related to the
commuters
um
they're they're thinking that it's going
to take at least three years before the
volumes return to where they were
related to the commuters
so that's reflected here in our revenue
estimates
um
so you can see
fy21
we're anticipating a 6.9 decrease over
fy20
and that's an 11 decrease over our
original plan our original plan was
137.8 million
for fy21 um and you can see we're
expecting 121 million so that's about 11
decrease
um and then moving forward we do
anticipate to start seeing you know
increases coming back
as the vaccines get out as people feel
more comfortable traveling vacationing
again
we anticipate to see some additional
revenue there
our other toll operating revenue
we're seeing some increases there and
that's
related to the collection of fees for
all electronic tolling so there are a
couple things that happen here
our third shift during covid
because the the reduced traffic volumes
were so um minimal
we moved to all electronic tolling
during the third shift late at night so
that has increased our collections on
our fees
and also in the future year projections
dover in rochester will begin
all electronic tolling at the end of
fiscal year 22 and into fy23
so
we see some increased other revenue
related to that for the for some
increased fees related to all electronic
tolling
um
so that's what we have on the turnpike
system i don't know if anyone has any
questions
on those estimates or anything going on
with the turnpike system right now okay
representative romney i mean
you have your hand up
well it's still up but i do have another
question
on what happens in all electronic
tolling when you don't have a
transponder
and you have no intention of getting one
because you live a long way away from
tolls
i can answer that representative um so
we have a couple different options um
one
um you can be you can have a license
plate account so for example you can go
on the system and you can put in your
license plate um
the make of your car
and the system will be able to marry
you know when you go through the tolls
the vehicle with with your account so
you can have a license plate account
with no transponder um
you can be if you don't if you don't
choose to um
you know set up a license plate account
you can actually go through the system
and then go online within seven days
and pay for the toll you can put in your
your license plate information your car
information the approximate time you
went through and then pay for the toll
that way um
if you decide not to do that then
um the turnpike system will look up
your account information well we'll look
up your license plate and then we'll
contact our dmv and then send you an
invoice
uh and typically because it's you know a
little more work to be able to do that
and the postage and all that
um
will will have an invoicing fee
um or a processing fee of a dollar
in addition to the toll to cover that
cost and that's payable within 30 days
um if
you the person does not pay with within
30 days then they'll get another notice
and that fee increases to a dollar fifty
to cover that additional postage um in
addition to the toll so there are
mechanisms in place to try to uh collect
from those individuals obviously we'd
love
uh for people to have transponders but
if they choose not to there are a number
of different ways that um they'll be
able to pay their toll
representative romney
yeah thank you uh real quick uh the
hooks at rest areas uh common man has
the contracts with those
the the the fees that they pay go to you
you folks
are what agency receive those receives
those funds
yes representatives so that's another
good question
so um that is actually a 35-year
contract that we have um with that group
um
that they're called granite state
hospitality but it is the common man um
aspect um and um you know in essence
they pay a minimum amount for um for
rent
it's 500 000 a year for both locations
and then on top of that based on sales
of food as well as based on sales of
volume of gas they pay an additional
amount um that um they need to break
you know certain thresholds of sales in
order to have those amounts triggered i
mean it's you know based on percentages
it's tiered so if they're more
successful they pay us a higher
percentage uh both on the
food and convenience store sales as well
as on the gas sales
so before covert hit um i believe they
paid
a little over 1.1 million
um you know for the fiscal year
um
for
their rent as well as food and and and
gas sales um so it is a very you know
they're they're having quite a bit of
success operating those facilities
the customers i think um
are you know feel the facilities and
services are you know uh very very good
there and
we are getting some revenue that comes
back into the turnpike fund um from from
those locations so they're very
successful in my mind it does yeah i
think so too
it it goes to the turnpike fund it's
what up
it goes somewhere in the turnpike fund
it goes into the turnpike fund in
essence it is um
in with all the rest of the revenue and
ultimately you know the turnpike revenue
is used for
operating the system um all the easy
pass expenses so that's the that's the
operation and maintenance aspect of it
um then there is debt service that's
paid
then the rnr work that is paid uh to
make sure the system is in good working
order and then everything else flows
down to the capital program okay great
thank you appreciate it okay since we
are out of time any further questions we
can do that at the work session with the
department
and we thank um both chris and
uh murray for that presentation thank
you
we need to get to the bishop game
commission which is scheduled for 11 30
and scott mason is like the executive
director and kathy labonte chief of
business division
they will
do the presentation so scott and kathy
uh jenny or
chris
scott's talking and
uh and he's not unmuted norman
my mistake i apologize
um
[Music]
um i wanted to just thank you folks for
the opportunity to speak before you
um i'm gonna have kathy labonte our
business manager give the presentation
and scott and kathy will you have uh
okay i have unmuted
absolutely
i'm not very proficient with um
[Music]
can you see it
no
okay i have it on my screen how do i get
your name is chris from the lba
hi chris
you see the share screen on the bottom
of the um zoom
frame it's in green i think it should be
if you click on that it's going to open
up all the open documents you have on
your computer
and then you can pick the slide that
you're you want to show the committee
and then you got to hit share and i
think that'll be in the bottom right
side
looks like at work
yep
okay
sorry about that this is my first time
doing this it's the first time for a lot
of us yes
so good morning everybody and thank you
for having us today uh this is director
mason's first time in front of house
ways and means and this is my first time
presenting as the chief of the business
division
um according to christie you are very
interested in the unrestricted fish and
game fund of course and the fish and
game fund ended fiscal year 20 with
7.6 million dollars in the unrestricted
fish and game fund and that is a very
good number it's the largest number
we've seen in quite a while
so per your request i did up this little
spreadsheet you had asked for a
list of all of our
individual parts of unrestricted revenue
types
for fiscal year 16 through 20 actuals
and that's what this
worksheet right here represents that is
up on your screen
and i would be more than happy to go
down through all of these different
types if that is your pleasure this
morning
and then this second tab right here
represents what i am anticipating for
fiscal year
23 and 24 what we budgeted
and also what i budgeted for fiscal year
21 which is the current budget but
given that we are
through halfway through the fiscal year
i have changed a couple of those
estimates uh as you know interest
earnings are much lower than what we
anticipated a couple years ago when we
went through the budget process
and a couple of these revenues have
already come in that would be the ohrv
and marine unrefunded road tolls those
are actual revenues that have already
been deposited into the unrestricted
fish and game fund
so with all of that being said if you
would like i can go down through these
different types of revenue sources or
answer questions at this point whatever
your pleasure is
if you would give us a high level of
each one of these lines
certainly
so the majority of these lines speak for
themselves certainly licenses is the
largest part of our unrestricted
revenues and that's where all of our
license revenue is deposited into when
it first hits the department
there are some licenses that are
dedicated license types for an example
when you purchase a fishing license
as a resident you would pay 44 dollars
for that fishing license 43 of that
license stays within this unrestricted
pot and one dollar of that license goes
into what we call the fisheries
dedicated
habitat account
so
that is our unrestricted license account
concord agent fees is in statute all
licensing agents receive one dollar from
the sale of each license type that they
sell
so this particular account is for that
one dollar agent fee that for all the
licenses that are sold here at the
2067 is kind of a melting pot
miscellaneous sales and income and the
biggest deposit that actually goes into
this account is
the internal administrative charge which
is charged to seven of our dedicated
internal accounts
and it's an over
overhead charge you might say it's 10 of
the revenues that are assessed on those
dedicated accounts
for income that is brought in during the
fiscal year
and that averages about 250 to 300 000
per year it is a one lump sum deposit
typically done
405 448 is court fines and penalties
kind of speaks for itself our
conservation officers out in the field
assess fines on people who are not
following our laws
and these fines and penalties are sent
over to us by the administrative office
of the courts on a regular basis
um
the ohrv agent
fees are the exact same thing as the
carcade agent fees only these are for
ohrv agent
registrations and
this
fee was actually just increased this
fiscal year to four dollars per
registration prior to that it was three
dollars per registration and prior to
that it was two dollars
and if i go back to the unrestricted
revenue
16 through 20 you can actually see how
it used to be a little bit less and it's
gone up a little bit more because that
fee has actually increased
i and that is all in statute
um license license agent fines and
penalties
actually is a fee paid by our license
agents if their
monthly remittance is not remitted by
the 14th
postmarked excuse me by the 14th
day of the month for the prior month
sales we have the ability to assess a
fine
on that license agent now the license
agent actually does have a right to
waive ask for a waiver of that fine if
they have a
a reason and during covid we waived a
lot of those fines and fees due to them
not having the personnel to be able to
submit their
monthly reports on time
interest earnings
that kind of
speaks for itself right now
interest earnings and deposits
went way up for 19 and 20 as you can see
and then i kind of put it way down i had
budgeted it at 50 and we are
significantly down in our interest
earnings
treasury actually calculates this based
on the fish and game fund component of
all of the revenues that are held by
treasury within the state
and as i said interest earnings are way
down so i
actually did a revised estimate i am not
anticipating
very good
income from our interest earnings at
this point in time we have received less
than two thousand dollars this fiscal
year
sale of surplus property is proceeds of
all fish and game equipment that is sent
to the department of administrative
services surplus
and then they
sell our surplus property and surplus
vehicles is the exact same thing only
this is just vehicles fishing game
vehicles that are sent over there
federal recoveries and indirect cost
that is a
pretty large pot just under a million
dollars and this actually is a
percentage that is charged to all of our
federal grants and federal grants within
the department is an average of six to
nine million dollars annually
and it's a cost to cover all of the
administrative overhead within the
department an administrative overhead is
personnel cost within the director's
office and the business office
and this rate is approved by the u.s
fish and wildlife service the
methodology to calculate this rate
and they are our
federal cognizant agencies so we have to
go through quite a process to have them
approve this rate
and
our final one here other than the
unrefunded road toll is gain management
transfers
game management transfers is initially
all license revenues are deposited into
that top revenue source 5221
and after all
monthly reconciliations
from the sale of each turkey bear and
waterfowl license sold
in each
moose application and subsequent permit
when drawn
are deposited into the dedicated game
management accounts
in all remaining funds from the sale of
those individual permits
are transferred into this game
management unrestricted account
that resides here
so that is a high level
description of what all of these
unrestricted
revenue sources are compiled of
all right
and do we have any questions from the
committee
i can't hear anything representative
romney you need to unmute yourself
yeah i'm sorry i did it again i just
want to know if they're done with the
presentation because i have a couple of
fun questions to ask them yes i am
yeah so uh where does the money from uh
what is it called north county
country law the animal planet tv show
that our uh
fish and game
wardens are are involved with
what is that
my understanding is they get 2 000 an
episode or the state does
for this where does that money go
the two thousand dollars per episode for
those funds actually do not come to the
fish and game department they actually
go to our non-profit partner of the
wildlife heritage foundation well they
do okay yes that's good
how about that's question norm
is the uh
safe hike
uh cards how's that program doing and
where does that money go
the pr that program is doing
much better than anyone had anticipated
actually and those funds are directly
deposited into the search and rush
rescue account
so
those funds are not represented here
because those are dedicated funds
they're dedicated to search and rescue
okay thank you you're welcome
representative
thank you on it's a little difficult
because you've got the 20
numbers on one page and the 21 numbers
on the next page
it looks to me like you're expecting a
decline of about 20
from the banner year of 20
as people
and go start to go out again
well we
we're being a little conservative
representative elmi we're we're not
quite sure with
covid and with the vaccine
if we're going to
experience
the banner year that we did last year
and
but at the same time we we need to be
conservative
all committee we're not seeing any
questions
um
do you have anything else to share with
the committee at this point in
time kathy i i do not sir
okay
then uh since
there are no other questions we
thank both you
and
scott
for their presentation here
thank you
thank you very much
thank you and so the committee
uh we should be
all done until one o'clock
and i would tell you don't
sign off just mute your
video and mute your audio
before you do that do you have any
questions
myself oh yeah i told you yesterday i
would let you know about the schedule
and
i did meet with aaron goulet
and we got approval for
the
second and third of
february
to meet
virtually
on a work session
so we're going to try that out meeting
virtually in our work session for the
revenues
on the second and thirds
foreign
to do
uh public hearings
on the 4th
of february
he still
hasn't cleared us for the 17th of
february
so
what we do have a schedule for is the
second and third work sessions and those
will be completely virtual
public hearings on our bills on the 4th
and the 11th
and hopefully we can finish them up on
so to the um do those sessions begin at
nine in the morning or ten
nine in the morning right nine in the
morning
so
i have to testify on the third can i
just leave my
i don't know how to do that and i have
to get back in
because i need to use my computer to
testify
uh
it won't be a problem
because you need the same computer
right but next on the third it will be
because i need the same computer so norm
i just did this yesterday i i
in the afternoon i had to testify
another committee
i just signed off and then signed on to
the other committee
and then you just the link is good you
just go back to the original link and
you go you go right back on great and i
did as well yesterday
yep great thank you
uh any
questions before lunch
norm one other thing you'd said in the
email you sent that we were likely to do
a work session on the 16th
17th
yes no the 16th
and
i hear that the governor may change the
date he presents his budget
and we're trying to get that nail down
because right after he presents his
budget we want to meet with
his budget
person
so
hang tight and we're working on these
things
representative major yes
um
gen four's internet went out and that's
why she's gone
but the tech support just took over the
hosting
so
and she's back i just i just got back
sorry guys if you needed me to do
something just repeat it no i think
we're good
okay surprising him of what had happened
yep okay yeah
all right anything else
yeah just for jen on
i think it was edie was saying that on
thursday she has to leave in the middle
and come back
to testify somewhere else
okay
and so she's going to drop off and then
she'll have to come back on and then
she'll have to
let back in
yeah as long as um represent tucker you
just use the same link you'll be just
fine but if you have any problems just
you know how to get in touch with me yes
okay anything else
it's in none and we will see you at one
o'clock
thank you so just mute your
so
hi dana
comptroller call it looks like you're
welcome to zoom enter your meeting id
enter your participant id followed by
pound otherwise just press pound to
continue
you have joined the meeting as an
attendee and will be muted throughout
the meeting this meeting is being
recorded
[Music]
jennifer let me know
when we're ready to start
comptroller call
can you hear us now
i can i'm on my phone line the computer
was not working
okay very good very good
sorry about that no you're afraid
dana this is chris i can share your
presentation to the committee and then
you can just kind of direct me where you
want to go
i i can see it on i mean i can see
online but i wasn't able to get in
through the my uh through my pc speaker
so
i can try to work it
yeah we have you on um
and i can promote you to panelists
uh we were able to see and hear you but
we couldn't uh you obviously weren't
hearing us
so you're not a panel a panelist um
using your computer
and you can see if your share screen
will work
okay
if you have enough hands to do all of
that
herself on her computer when she gets
there
okay i'm trying
it's not you're getting there i think
you just chose the whiteboard
oh gosh
so just um bring up your
other file you'll be good
yeah i'm trying to
um
well
thing
if chris can share it i can work from
that
okay
yeah i can do that
apologize we do a lot on teams here so
it's a little different on zoom
okay
oh
dana carl is the comptroller from the
department of administrative services
and she's going to be reporting on
other revenue sources okay dana
thank you good afternoon um
normally commissioner arlinghaus is with
me but he was tied up in another hearing
right now so i'm gonna go through it
without him
but um
if we want to go to slide two
um we could asked for some information
about the
how the monthly revenue focus is
developed and how the
revenue plan is developed by our office
so i have a few bullets on that
if anyone is not on the distribution
list for the monthly revenue focus feel
free to touch base with jen or chris and
they can connect you with my office we
do email that out we also post it
on our website as is noted here
usually it comes in out the first about
the second or third business day of each
beginning of each month reporting on the
cash basis collections from the previous
months
this is just reporting on unrestricted
revenue sources
today my presentation is about the
category of other but the monthly
revenue focus reports all unrestricted
revenue sources
including the dra revenue sources
business taxes liquor etc
so that report you should be familiar
with again it's cash basis
so there are some
annual audit adjustments that take place
but it is generally meant to give you a
sense each month of how we are doing as
compared to plan
the second bullet talks about the plan
which is put out at the beginning of the
each fiscal year and it's based on the
adopted budget law so it's really an
annual plan
and we work with each agency that
collects the funds to split it up into
monthly increments um based on
their track record of collections um and
historical patterns
that way it gives us a sense of what are
the big months versus smaller months
especially when it pertains to business
taxes
but there is no actual monthly plan by
law it's an annual plan so
generally as long as we meet plan for
the fiscal year we're in good shape even
if we are behind during the course of
the year
and we talk about that in the focus as
well
and then each the plan itself is based
on
as i said the adopted budget as well as
any other
items that may impact the plan uh
schedule two adjustments that sort of
thing that come out of typically out of
a committee conference
anything that is on the
lba surplus statement that they produce
is what we incorporate um and then
sometimes there are things such i
mentioned in the last bullet
where an item we don't change the plan
if we're no if we're aware of something
that's going to impact the actual
revenues collected
we might footnote it in the plan for
instance
this past year was
liquor had a larger
distribution to the alcohol abuse fund
so we've been noting that throughout the
year
that doesn't impact the actual adopted
budgeted plan it just is something
noteworthy
that we draw attention to if we if we're
aware of something that comes about
through
other legislation or other enacted items
so i can take any questions on that or
uh there's no questions at this point in
time
okay
so as i mentioned um the
while we do
as in the accounting function for the
state track all unrestricted revenue
sources um here in das we as far as
budgetary estimates we handle the
category of other
a lot of things are in there you'll see
further in the presentation
at some points there's been 200 revenue
sources there's about 140 right now
active revenue sources that roll up into
other
and i'll talk today about some of the
more sizable ones
again most of these are not collected by
admin services but we do
report on them all and try to do any the
best estimating that we can of the group
as a whole
the two that we do
calculate and collect are the
reimbursement for statewide indirect
costs which is also known as ycap
and then also the recovery for
post-retirement benefits and i'll talk a
little about those on the next slide but
those are both calculated by my office
and we handle the billion collections
with the internal state agencies on
those
most of the others are external revenue
sources
unrestricted revenue sources that
support other agencies operations
so the two mentioned that are typically
fairly large in this category or
interest in abandoned property and i
know treasury is up next after me so i'm
not going to get too deep into that
and then there's a few
mentioned here from department of safety
secretary of state
and then a whole slew of miscellaneous
other
so if you want to go to the next
page
we can talk about the couple that are
collected here in admin services
because we're the central service agency
we
do the calculation to
what those costs are each year and we
get that
cost recovery rate is approved by the
federal government and we bill and
collect with agencies
there are some timing differences that
the overall the category of other is is
significantly a variable type of
category it is difficult to have actual
trend analysis on any of these line
items
indirect costs in particular
as well as post retirement
they do tend to
vary from year to year based on a very
detailed and intricate calculation
that i won't go into here but we work
with the agencies to budget and collect
those funds
and that basically allows us to
tap into federal revenue sources to help
recover the costs
of some things that are in the in the
general fund
so it comes into the unrestricted
general fund revenue
to offset
other general funded expenses
and the funding sources for federal
grants and such
for the most part
so
if we want to go on to the next slide
i'll talk quickly about post retirement
and then we'll talk about the numbers
so post retirement is very similar it is
collecting recovery
from federal grants and
non-generally funded revenue sources to
support the costs of
retiree health benefits that
are funded through the general fund
budget
so that we have a we also have a
calculated rate
each year and we charge the agencies
for that cost recovery
so on the next slide we can talk a
little bit about the magnitude of these
dollars
this is a history back to fiscal 16 of
actuals
i'll skip over miscellaneous for a
moment but the second line second and
third line is the reimbursement of
indirect costs and post-retirement which
we just discussed
as you can see
they're fairly close each year but there
are some significant years where just
because of the
change in the budgetary rate in the way
it is calculated
from a timing perspective that can
change also sometimes it's affected by
when the agency actually pays
so we may put a bill out and then there
may be cross
payment
across different fiscal periods and this
is all cash basis numbers here so
we can
give you a sense that it does vary from
year to year but it's order of magnitude
it can be
somewhat similar so we've budgeted we've
shown you our projected budget for this
fiscal year that we're in 21 as well as
22 and 23
just based on what we think that we're
going to end up billing the agencies for
so the top two are the most significant
um just moving back up to the first line
the miscellaneous other revenue that's
the 140 or so
varied sources that i discussed
throughout our uh
when we move to the next slide i'll show
you some of those but some of those we
track individually and some of them we
don't really track because they're just
so small
so the rest of this slide is
really what treasury's going to get into
but i can pause here and take any
questions on the numbers if you have any
uh
any questions representative brownie
thank you for your presentation um
thank you for your presentation uh i i
always get confused on this one
so on the on the reimbursement of
indirect costs
so to an agency this is an expense
to you
uh you your your agency uh you it's a
it's a revenue
but i'm trying to reconcile how is it a
really a new revenue
um i mean the agencies are being paid
so the money that's coming in from other
revenues
are budgeted to them
and then they're they're sending some of
it to you so are we double counting
revenues here
no because it's a it's the source of the
revenue so
we're uh having agencies charge back
through their grant process they're
charging their federal counterparts
for a recovery
of items like for instance central
accounting and central financial data
management those are all central
services that are budgeted in the
general fund
so we're recovering the costs that
everyone is benefiting from
from the federal
source funds non-general source funds so
it's sort of moving federal funds into
unrestricted general funds which
supports the costs of those
cost centers that are
budgeted only in the general fund okay
if this didn't happen
yeah it makes a lot of sense okay i
really appreciate that i always get a
little confused on that one but i i see
i understand what you're saying thank
you uh yeah it is it is somewhat
confusing because yes you will see it in
the budget as we mentioned in the
presentation it's in the it's in a class
in the detailed budget for each agency
so
um you know if you go to the
department of transportation budget and
you see a class line
for what we call swag cap or indirect
cost recovery it is an expense to them
but they're
getting that from their grant funding
all right uh mr chair just wanna follow
up on that
follow up
just follow okay thank you um
so without that this is just a process
that's in place to make it easier for
this
instead of each agency having to worry
about dealing with the feds to get their
payments you you folks handle it is that
it
yeah and it and i just it's a
das collects the ricotta recovery but it
does not go back into our admin services
budget so i guess that's why some people
get confused and they're like why am i
paying admin services for this
it's not going it's going to the state's
bottom line so it's going to the general
fund unrestricted revenue to support all
generally funded costs but
but yeah it is it is better to do it
from a central standpoint and the
federal
the federal cognizant agency that we
work with approves our calculation and
the rate that we charge the agencies
so there's oversight
i understand thank you very much
you're welcome
representative ames
thank you
um
this this goes back to the monthly
revenue focus
report and uh
and uh the uh as
undoubtedly you know the dra
uh collected quite a lot of money in
july
that the kafir has charged to the prior
prior year
fiscal year and
my question is exactly how is that
showing
on the
focus for this year the your reports for
this year
have you removed that amount of money
so that when we look at the dra
total for the end of let's say the six
month period
that total will be without
the
roughly 30 million dollars i think
yes we do we are carrying that
adjustment each month on the
year-to-date analysis so
not on the m it wouldn't affect the
month to month analysis but on the
year-to-date page which is page three of
our focus
we do have a line at the bottom
that
shows the cash basis collections
year-to-date and then removes that 30
million to show
what you can consider to be
available for fy21 so we do carry that
adjustment it's uh it's unusual we don't
normally because it is a cash basis
report it is meant to be cash basis and
and we do make accrual adjustments every
year um so it's not unusual to have
accruals that we reverse out of prior
and add in a new year that is that
happens every year but this year because
of that timing aspect we reversed out
last year's accruals but then added
a whole lot more to the new year so it
really kind of swayed
the comparison across the two years so
we have been carrying that adjustment
and footnote language trying to explain
thank you mr chairman uh
[Music]
post-retirement benefits recovery can
you take us through why it swoops up 19
to 20 and then
then you think it's going to
be half
in 21 and then
good question
it is it's a complicated calculation
i have a whole
unit within my division that
that's not 100 of what they do but
that's a good chunk of what they do
each year and it is impacted by
payroll costs and
timing differences between the years
so
it's a little difficult to explain
exactly what the dip is we we felt that
it was sort of
more of a temporary type of thing
an adjustment if you will but it does it
does generally
fall somewhat in line
each year
i think but some of it is like i said
affected with timing of collections
sometimes we can't necessarily control
when
the agency pays in for that item
so a lot of it is is really related to
timing
and we're hoping that in the next couple
years it smooths out
but i don't i don't have a great answer
because there are so many different
elements of the calculation that go into
it um
perhaps i can have my team put together
a more detailed analysis that we could
provide to the committee
after your meeting and and try to handle
it that way but it is it is somewhat of
thank you that would be great to have
some kind of idea of what that is
yeah we do we do some um some analysis
for chairman for commissioner ollie
house and and try to help him understand
um the year to year fluctuation in that
so i will get something to the committee
that hopefully
provides some additional details
thank you any further questions from
anybody else
i don't see any so you can
you can continue
okay i think we'll go on to the next
slide which is
like i said a little bit more detail in
the line items that make up the
miscellaneous portion
um so again this top section of this
chart is what we call the tracked
accounts
uh where we track each month we we
actually allocate a monthly plan
estimate and we track each month how
they're coming in
and then sort of
i apologize the numbers didn't show up
on the cell when i put it into the
powerpoint but uh sort of down down
towards the bottom there's a line that
says um all others untracked uh it's
about seven million dollars for the 2223
year
those those are
the other
130 or so items that come in to to all
different agencies for unrestricted
revenue sources
so a lot of a lot of little things but
over the years we've tried to track the
bigger line items
in here and
sometimes the
trends change if something
moves from restricted to unrestricted so
that
a law may
change a particular revenue source where
it used to be unrestricted and then it
gets changed to restricted
i guess the only the recent change
is is in the uh oplc
board fees we had those all moved into
restricted so we no longer track those
in this
section um that showed up on a previous
slide
but otherwise most everything here
is somewhat consistent year over year
as i mentioned treasury will talk about
interest there they're showing down at
the bottom that they don't expect to
collect any so you'll see in the uh
column that says 21 variants from plan
um i i'm expecting at this point we're
halfway through fiscal 21 i expect to be
about seven million dollars
short of our plan which was 71.8 million
so we expect to collect about 64.8
on that plan for fy21
for a variety of items but primarily due
to interest
and then we expect 22 and 23 to come
where some come somewhat in line with 68
to 70 million dollars overall
typically if we're short in one line
item we may be over in another and it
evens out to about 68 to 70 million
uh yes representative susan amy
thank you mr chairman
uh
dana do you have in here the initial
plate fund and vanity plate
which safety also talked to us about it
doesn't appear in two places does it
correct they they collect it we report
it
so all of these items uh the vast
majority like i said of other is
collected by the agencies themselves
um
we did not for for this exercise um a
mid-year
budget checkup for fy21 um we don't
typically
go back out and
check with every agency to see where
they're doing we we just kind of track
it globally so
we can always
make adjustments if needed um if safety
if there were going to be a big change
in the line item we would footnote it
and like i mentioned we would we would
hope to be over in some other line i'm
so that at the end of the day as a group
uh they
balance out but
but yeah safety would be the best source
of any information on that item going
into the future
right and they did take that one down a
fair amount because there haven't been
very many initial plates
okay
yeah we would probably we didn't make
any major adjustments
other than treasury
for this particular
estimating
process but again that is because for
the most part we usually come in
but that's good to know
any other questions from the committee
okay um
the next four slides i don't have a lot
to speak to again these are just to give
you a sense
of the variety of items that roll up
into unrestricted other
the shaded ones are the ones that we
track and then all of the others
we just report on as they come in
so
i think i covered most of the items you
wanted to discuss but
i can certainly
elaborate on anything else
um
representative romney you have a
question
you're muted
pat
thanks thanks uh norm uh so these all go
into general fund correct
or is that the education fund
no uh
she
that's a good question i think they
believe
they are all general funds we don't
typically have a lot of other in the
education trust fund maybe some interest
but these are all general okay thank you
representative
thank you
could you tell us uh how you decide
which ones to track i notice you've got
agriculture economic poisons as a
trackable item and i
don't remember that one being much
i think it's just been based on highest
dollar value but
you're you're correct some may some may
shift over the years
um we have
that one
yeah back on chris moved up back to that
slide that one's about a million and a
half um
so i think that i think
most of these are just have been
historical tract items we i personally
in the time i've been here haven't done
a lot of adjusting to this other than
removing things that don't
apply anymore
so
we can do we can certainly take a look
at some of the other and see if any have
risen to the levels of being say over a
million dollars or so but
generally these have been the
thank you i can see that the gas fitters
are down to half a million
an aircraft
yeah they're most you know most revenue
sources have a a purpose in them so
they're
usually restricted so that there's not a
lot
you know i don't know that you want to
have a lot in miscellaneous other
that's not usually the goal so
this is just kind of the place for
things that don't have a specific
purpose
thank you norm um yeah uh another
question here um i noticed on the one of
the early slides office of professional
licensure
uh that we've done work with in the past
uh but i guess the statute change and i
we must admit at least i must have
missed it that it's
now dedicated fund those monies
starting in uh ninth fiscal year 19
and uh but would you were you around
then when that happened and what was the
logic of that happening
i was around i'm wondering if christie
has a little bit more logic but i
i do know it it uh
it generated a lot of discussion
um and there was times when they
you know they couldn't
basically by not including it in the
general fund they they changed the way
they budgeted for those so there was a
lot of discussion i don't know if chris
wants to chime in on any of the
particulars
i don't really have a lot to add um that
was a separate bill that went through
basically the idea of the bill was that
they'd collect all their fees they'd
have a budget that they would pay
using those fees and anything left at
the end of the year
would transfer back into the general
fund
okay so the agency has has had a number
of um
directors over the years and and i know
they're still trying to
um
basically organize themselves so that
their laws are all clear as to who sets
fees and how fees get set
i think there's a bill that's going to
come out this year that's further
cleaning up some of their language so i
think it was an effort to try to get
everything in the same bucket so that
you had a good idea of how much was
collected
so that when they were budgeting you
could say yeah this is how much you have
that's an appropriate amount to to put
in a budget
i think representative remember you know
a bunch of years ago we spent a lot of
time
setting those fee levels um for these
and this must have been come dissent it
was a senate bill it looks like senate
bill uh 531
uh in 2018
um i just don't remember this um
happening it could have been one of
those bills that was buried in the
budget i don't know
um but i don't know represent major or
mr representative army do you remember
this happening
on i worked on it quite a lot if that's
well right you worked on with me we all
worked on this right no i worked on this
last year oh okay okay i will uh let you
chime in then
i'll back i'm almost at that
major
go ahead reps around
thank you
on
this bill on the bill yeah it was a
senate bill i jammed it through
at the last minute the couple of years
ago
and i was pretty skeptical of it because
we'd worked so hard on this and they had
not gone through ways and means they
only went through i think it was edna
and
they
they did have terrible trouble at the
beginning they went through three
directors their new director seems
extremely competent
and
on
chair went after this was that they put
in that bill that's going to pass this
year
and to change everything again
and they were undergoing a fiscal audit
that they had asked for
so not a fiscal one a performance audit
um because they were in such trouble
on
and so we looked at each other and said
this
is not the time for them to change
everything again in law
not knowing that this new director
who wasn't director yet actually was
quite competent and had created this
this bill so the bill is going through
again this year it got killed last year
it's the only one the house killed out
so
we're hoping it is now a dedicated fund
and
on the dedicated fund committee which i
hope will be on still
is going to to be looking at it on this
summer because we were told the
performance audit would be finished this
they were going to do a fiscal audit
because we were concerned with the whole
thing
as well
and this summer the dedicated fund
committee whoever is doing it will be uh
be looking at that
again
but ways and means got dealt out of the
picture unfortunately
okay
um a question from representative hacken
phillips
yes thank you mr chair i am wondering um
dana on your slide number seven
there is a
line item sale of real property
administrative services is the agency
but then no numerical values across the
graph could you speak to us please
yes we have if um
if there is a planned sale of a general
fund property uh we would report it here
but that doesn't necessarily happen
every year so there may be other funded
properties that dot might sell
right-of-ways that sort of thing but
this would be
general fund oriented properties
and there are none that i know of
upcoming
you have your hand raised you have
yeah but my hand really wasn't up but
i'll just chime in on the last comment i
mean would it would the example of that
be the uh
the school i think it's the hospital
lebanon the school or the or the old
hospital up in lebanon it's been up for
a long time
lakes region maybe
say again
um i'm not sure about the lebanon one i
know um
i'm not i'm trying to think
sorry go ahead i'm at laconia
i'm sorry i meant laconia laconia yeah
right
yeah that if if that were that would be
reported here because that's been that's
been up for sale for a long time and
it's just sitting there right
correct uh yeah i don't know the act i
am not uh
the source of the status on that
particular one so
um if charlie
if charlie were with us he would know
but that would be an example of if it
did sell with one up here
yeah
yeah if it was funded with general funds
to be purchased to begin with but we
don't sell a whole lot of property
well example is that uh liquor sold uh
an old store but that that stays within
the liquor commission um
they they sold an old building that they
had two they think they were yeah
it depends
typically if it was funded through
liquor funds yes right right sometimes
that varies depending on the original
as far as selling
property
is it you end up leasing a lot of
especially if it
is that true
uh yeah we do have a lot of leases those
are managed here in admin services in
any other questions
wow a way i had a schedule here
i know i i can't really feel an hour to
just with other
and we could talk about the kafir or any
other items you might want to talk about
but
um other revenue is is a small piece of
the puzzle
um that's not a bad idea
give a high level of the chapter
and how it varies from the
revenue focus and
everything else that we report
on a cash basis
did you folks get copies
um
by any chance
i
i did i
made a copy of the chair against it i
think
yeah
no okay this is chris um just to let you
know we do have copies for the committee
they're sitting in my office their hard
copy we're just trying to figure out how
to get them to the various committees
because there are a couple of uh agency
reports that we're trying to determine
how to the best way to get them out
and so we do it in a consistent fashion
between finance ways and means and
public works
so hopefully those will be out soon
uh actually
the whole committee even though we have
a hearing tomorrow public hearings
i think there's only seven of us are
going to show up and everybody else is
going to do it virtually
so probably it'd be best if you could
mail those out to the committee members
i i think we would all would appreciate
it
uh understand um represent major the the
issue we're dealing with is
um the volume of mail that's being
requested and we're trying to determine
the best way to go about that
that's one small document for for this
agent for this committee but we've got
finance as well so we're trying to have
a consistent approach to the committees
in terms of how we distribute documents
so that we're not mailing thousands of
pieces of paper to every member of a
committee that may not want it
so
i get direction from the lba on what how
he wants to handle that i will certainly
make sure the committee gets what's due
to them
right so for now um it is available on
our website the same web
website address that i gave you for the
revenue focus
we do keep all of our accounting reports
on that same page so the kafir the
federal single audit the dedicated funds
report all of those reports if you visit
that
accounting web page reside in one place
and they're all available to look at
online
kafir in particular is nice to look at
online because it is it is a book it's a
very large document so
you can
poke around as you like online
i think some of the
the most i guess relevant pieces would
be
in the beginning there's a transmittal
letter
from the commissioner from charlie
arlinghaus and in that we put the
general and education trust fund surplus
statements so typically that's a good
place to look at the very beginning of
the document there's a
nice letter that talks about all the
things that transpired over the year and
the general and education trust fund
surplus statements are
more of a statutory reporting item
they're not an audited financial
statement so they go in the transmittal
letter we prepare those here at admin
services and
the auditors don't typically focus on
that area
but it is important to legislators
because that is the presentation that
you're used to looking at so
all of our
unrestricted revenue numbers
show up there in the surplus statements
and you can see where we ended the
balance for the year in both the general
and education trust fund
so that's a helpful document
we also
the audited financial statements if
you're familiar with a typical balance
sheet income statement type presentation
that is that is what the auditors give
us an opinion on we received
an unmodified opinion this year which
means all was good
um
happy to report that even with
our teams being almost 100 remote and
the audit being 100 remote which has
never happened before we were able to
get the audit done on time and with a
clean opinion so
i'll take every opportunity i can to
talk about that
congratulations
we're very proud of that here so
um thank you so so that's a good
document uh the balance sheet this year
has a new column in it so you would see
i apologize i can't throw it up right
now but you would see a general fund an
education trust fund the highway fund
and then we have the new
coronavirus relief fund column
so we were able to show separately
not all money that's come from the cares
act in general but the 1.25 billion that
was allocated to the state
that we received up front and that the
gopher office has been distributing
for the last almost a year
that we have highlighted in our kafir
report this year
so you can see that information and the
auditors have also audited that
and then sort of in the the back section
is where you'll find a lot of the items
we've been talking about the
unrestricted revenue details and
that's where you would see we don't
provide necessarily a reconciliation
between cash and accrual basis but you
will find if you look at a focus report
for the fiscal year and you look at the
kafir unrestricted revenue page
for general funds they will be different
numbers and i know in the past
chris has provided the committee with
some information on that too
they do differ as i said every every
year because of accrual adjustments but
this particular year being a big one
you will see a difference in the total
unrestricted revenue
per the kaffir versus what's reported in
the cash basis focus so
next time we're together in person i'd
be happy to point those pages out to you
but
for now
i'd encourage you to go to our webpage
and
find all of the documents that we
produce here at admin services
yeah what i usually do is i go to the
cafe and i pull these pages out to be
printed
yes uh you know the information all in
there is important but there's
definitely pages that you want to focus
saying then uh thank you dana uh
you're welcome anytime
okay
all right have a good afternoon
thank you
the treasurer is supposed to comment uh
too is
is she here yet
i don't see her um in the attendee list
quite yet
okay
when she does show up we can
i don't think we'll have a problem
getting started
really i hope not
because i look at the attendee list
and you'll see the ones in the attendees
that's correct so we have two
two people there right now and so i'm
just watching to see
um when treasurer mezzapelli um comes to
join us
i don't know if you if you guys have
anything to talk about or maybe you just
want to take
you know a five minute break i'm sure
she'll be in soon
yeah why don't we take a break until
hi treasurer mizipelli
this is jen the committee researcher i
just wanted to let you know that i've
promoted you to panelists
um and you can mute one when they're
ready to begin the committee's just on a
quick break until
so
bob elliott
yes
fine
okay
very complicated
but i would prefer to have it in writing
so i could study it more
because you veterans all know from being
there so long
exactly what's going on but the
conversations are limited to three or
four people
and not the nine new members that are on
the board
so they must be having the same
difficulties that i'm having too is
following it because it's so intense
and so complicated
well
what we've been doing thus far is really
an introduction
and uh going over all the various uh
factors involved with the revenues
from the economics through the agency
heads
and then the work starts when we start
having the work sessions
and when we go to work sessions we'll
bring these all these agency heads back
in again even economists if we have to
okay and uh
everybody
hopefully will be participating asking
the questions especially the
the new people
because you really don't get to
understand it until you participate
okay
well i'm not shy
good i know you're not that's why
you don't have to agree with me
let me ask you a question mr chairman
yes
again from a newbie perspective
you know and tell me if i'm wrong in
assuming this but i'm i'm listening to
this and i would agree with bob that
this is
it's complicated especially when you
don't understand the history
and all the mechanics of where funds
shift to and from and
you know the previous bills that have
been passed and
changed the the these budgets
having said that
um
how much of the work that we do
regarding the new bills coming forward
influence the budget going forward
meaning
say for instance you just got rid of a
revenue source of a significant amount
in a bill
how does that impact what the work we're
doing in the work groups next week and
beyond that
okay
first of all
the work we've been doing right now has
to do with the
revenue streams
that are in existence for current law
and
have nothing to do with the legislation
our base for revenues is what does our
current law say
and then
if we can pass revenues such as
credits and things like that then that
will affect
what our revenues are either drive them
up or drive them down
whatever the revenues are
is what the finance has to live with
it seems like we're doing it
concurrently that's what i was saying it
seems like
we're trying to figure out you know i've
been involved in making budgets for
hospitals
but we kind of understood the ground
rules and it feels like we're trying to
do
a budget in revenue predictions
concurrently with potential you know
bills that may change our assumptions is
what i was thinking so
right you have to first of all
get current law is going away that's
your base
okay and whatever you do to affect that
is coming up in
the bills the bills may be
individual bills or it could be part of
the budget process
those are the budgets under house bill
one all the appropriations
and to make the budget work
you take the revenue projections that we
have
and then in house bill one will be well
changing a rate or adding a new
norm can i take a crack at this sure
jim
it's real simple between now and the
middle of february
we're not going to worry about any of
the other bills that are coming up that
are going to change revenues up or down
we're going to do strict what's current
law
that's what we're going to base our
numbers on then later on
because you got to remember budget bills
revenue bills any kind of bill has to
pass both houses
so we are not going to know what's
passed and then the governor has to sign
it
so we won't know until
way into june
what's
law new law in terms of and then and
maybe chris can explain that he's paying
it he may uh
that they they call it the back of the
budget they make these the ads revenues
that subtract what wasn't chris jump in
at this point
lit up there chris so just just to
further explain
um
representative abrami and reps and major
absolutely correct you're going to make
your revenue forecast on current law
but you also know there's bills out
there that may have an impact on that
and the house may pass some of those
bills
our office the legislative budget
assistant office will take those bills
into consideration
as we build the surplus statement and as
the finance committee is building its
budget and will make them aware that
um the house has passed house bill 123
and that's going to you know change the
business tax rates by increasing the bet
by a point and decreasing the bpt by a
point and this is the impact on revenue
so we would
carry a line on what you so we'll hear
referred to as schedule 2
of the surplus statement and that will
be a revenue adjustment to take care of
that so you end up with a house
so whatever budget you pass
with the trailer bill there will be a
surplus associated with that which would
be the house position then the senate
would take their crack at it
they may or may not agree with some of
the bills that are being passed by the
house
um they may have other ideas that they
want to do so you would end up with a
senate position and we would reflect any
changes that
were contained either in a separate bill
or
um were were brought into house bill 2
or the trailer bill
um and then again at the committee a
conference the house and the senate
would um iron out any differences and
then a final surplus statement would be
issued and with all the revenue
adjustments and that is what um the
comptroller mentioned earlier in her
presentation they would take that
surplus schedule
and then build the revenue plan off from
that so they would look at the
unrestricted revenues in the back of
house bill 1 and then any other
adjustments that were
captured in the surplus statement to
build your official revenue plan
and that is why i
that's why our job is never done
really
we'll be continuing looking at those
revenues
all the way up to the committee of
conference and when we say look at those
revenues current law and all the
proposed legislation
in
the budget bill and separate bills
that's very appreciated and reassuring
because i woke up in the middle of night
with sweaty palms
thinking that we were changing an engine
in the middle of a flight you know so
it's helpful thank you
all right good uh ben
i have a question mr chairman yes
the question is
uh last week we received uh
a mailing of all the bills and then on
thursday's meeting
at 9 00 a.m and 9 30
house bill 533 and house bill 568 were
not included
in that package
is that just an oversight or
those those two bills which are the
first things on the agenda
five three three and five six eight
yeah those are what we're going to be
dealing with tomorrow i believe yeah
please yes tomorrow
no
i'm sorry to interrupt but um
just to explain
there were some bills that were missing
for each committee because we were only
able to mail out what we've received
from the print shop
so far and there are certain bills that
had not come
back from the print shop
at the time of mailing so that is
probably why they weren't included in
your first mailing
what i would do is
go to the
website
and download the bill
that's the only way you'll have a copy
of the bill
okay what website is that
you go to
nh.gov
i can send him the link representing me
okay
it's not going to appreciate that
jennifer
why don't you send it to all of us yeah
i will do that that'd be great and when
you pull up the website the first thing
will be is a place you put your bill
number in you put that in
click on it
the bill itself
the
schedule
i can't think of all
but all the information relative to that
bill the docket it's been scheduled etc
okay i just don't want the champion i
think i'm not doing my homework
you need to pick up the pdf
not the text version because the pdf
will have line numbers and somebody may
say look at line 16 on page two
that's a that's important the pdf copy
all right we we have to get started on
the
the treasury department
uh with monica
mezzo
p e l l e the treasurer
and thomas uh mcassby
the abandoned property director
and the treasury department you're on
now
uh thank you very much mr chairman and
and thank you everyone uh good afternoon
everyone members of the committee
against state treasurer monica
mazzapelli and uh with me this mo this
afternoon i've asked um director of
abandoned property to join me um tom i
can ask me should be on i think um
i'm not sure if he was able to uh
i don't see him but it is i just
promoted him to panelist he's oh
excellent analyst
great thank you very much
so um
again thanks for inviting me back um
what i want to do is share my screens so
i'm just going to try to do that right
now
can you see my screen now yes we can
very good
um
so um when i was asked to uh to come
back and speak of abandoned property i
just thought it uh
you know in addition to the items that
um
were part of the the request i just
thought that providing an overview of
the program it would be a good start for
especially for members that are new to
the committee
um
so i will um so my intent today is our
intent is to again provide an overview
so we'll cover uh very briefly how the
promo program works and
we'll talk about reporting of abandoned
property
the claims against that property
how we determine the general fund is
treatment
and some of the trends and initiatives
that may impact uh this activity and for
that i will ask director makanespi to
to provide some details
so again i will start with a brief
um charges the estate treasuries
abandoned property division with the
responsibility of recovering and
returning intangible property to right
to individuals to the rightful owners
so typically
the property that that we receive
is cash from dorman accounts
so and it could also include securities
such as stock
um
mutual funds
[Music]
excuse me hey jen can you uh mute
the ones
thank you so uh so so so we receive cash
from german accounts and also securities
um
could be in the form of stock of mutual
funds
um so this property properties really
come from institutional holders that
report to us and remit to us
and primarily those are banks create
unions corporations insurance companies
uh governmental agencies municipalities
um so
each october we publish as many of you
know may know we publish an annual
listing of all the names that we receive
um every year and and so we we
we're less than the union leader mainly
the list of properties in the list of
names with the last known address
we also do a mailing in the form of
postcard notification
again send it to this
we sent it to the last known address
that we have on record and those
mailings usually happen in august in
september
uh of each year
so um so in addition to that the way we
advertise um so that's the way one way
we advertise but um in 2020 we upgraded
our unclaimed property system so
individuals now can now
do online searches directly into our
database
and if if
also if they want to if they want to
start initiate a claim online they can
also do that and also upload the support
and documentation to be able to claim
those funds
the other way we um
our program works is we we also
participate um we still participate uh
using the missingmoney.com which is a
multi-state database of unclaimed
property so we still use that uh so we
have a variety of ways of how
so moving on to the the reporting of of
properties so this this chart really
shows
the activity over the last 10 fiscal
years so
um during that time we have
um collected about 177 million from
holders and that's an average of 17.7
um also when um
so in fiscal year 20 we we receive
approximately 20 million
and that was um
from approximately four four thousand
seven hundred institutional holders so
that is also shown on the next chart
so this chart shows um the activity
um
over the last ten years
of holders reporting to the division
so again in 2020
um approximately four thousand seven
hundred institutional holders were
reported to us
um and and that was again about 20
million dollars and also delivered over
8.9 million
the division paid
approximately 7.5 million to citizens
and that's about
[Music]
6868 claims
so again this chart shows the activity
over the last 10 years
we return approximately 66.9 million in
property
which is an average of 6.6 million a
year
uh so this brings us to um you know this
gma calculation this is how we this is
how we calculate the amount that we
remain to the right to the general fund
um so in this calculation this is the
fiscal year 20 calculation
in fiscal year 20
we um
so
what i what i mean to say here is the
law allows us to
again the program is assigned to to
recover those those properties those
funds and also return those funds to
individual to individuals
and encompa in corporations too
and so the law allows us to um
you know if we are unable to return that
property after three years
those funds can be as cheated to county
treasurers
and
the rest to the general fund so
in fiscal year 20 um
this is a calculation that we use
and
this is the the reported amount
from fiscal year 17 was 12 million
then
we are also able to liquidate
the securities that we receive that was
2.9 million we were able to subtract the
minister of expenses for the program
and also deduct the county payments so
in fiscal year 20 we um
uh
we returned to a general fund
approximately 11.7 million
so i think in the past what uh what i've
mentioned uh to this committee is
we
we have a way we we know already
we have a way to estimate how much we
potentially could achieve to the general
fund
because we know
how much we have received in a
particular fiscal year
and in the average that we return we
return each year
so the typical unknown is
is the amount of securities that we
liquidate so when we liquidate
securities we have
a certain number of securities that we
we're about to liquidate but it really
depends on the market and the capital
markets at the time we sell those
securities
um
how much we're going to really receive
so in fiscal year 20 unfortunately was
one of those
years that the market was not performing
well because it was about the time
when
when we had the downturn in the market
in um so unfortunately at that time we
receive less that we will normally
receive
however
we we do not time the market so we have
some years that we are also able to
benefit from a bull market so and that
is is probably shown better in the next
couple of slides so this slide
also shows the activity over the last 10
years that we we have as cheetah to the
general fund and the top chart shows um
what we remem uh what relates to the
the cash that we receive from
from
institutional holders um and the the
table and the bottoms really shows how
much we've been able to liquidate
um those the the proceeds from those uh
securely with securities liquidations
um so again in 2020 it wasn't it wasn't
a very good year for for this type of
proceeds uh but for example in 2014
um 2018 2018 we were able to take
advantage of the values of
the the fair market value of those
properties
so the
next chart really shows how much we have
in total uh limited to the general fund
um i think i am covering my own notes
there um so over the past 10 years the
division has us cheated i'm sorry
the division has exceeded approximately
140 million to the general fund which is
an average of 14 million
so so with that information we're able
to uh at least project that in fiscal
year 21
we should be able to
exchange approximately 17.3 million
um the same um
for the upcoming budget and fiscal year
22 and 23
we believe we could um we could exceed
16.8 million and 22 and 18.4 million and
23. and this this really is based on we
use a 10-year average for our
projections
and and it's based on information that
we already have how much we typically
return
to individuals and corporations each
year and that allows us to estimate
these numbers that
okay well i uh with that information um
i think i'll turn it over to director
makanespi
to provide us more details on the trends
in initiatives before you do that could
you explain
uh the payments the county so
we use the same process um is is
you know i probably asked uh director
mcconaughey to explain this a little
more uh but it is the same process as
the cash that we have collected that
relates
that um this is the piece that probably
gonna need uh his assistance um the
where the owners the last known address
of the owners
um are part of
and and so if we are unable to return
those funds to
to those owners then the counties
receive
we are able to um so once we achieve
even to the general fund once we're able
to cheat to the county treasurer's and
also to a general fund an owner can an
owner can always come come back to us
and and request those funds we have the
ability to
um to go back we we actually go to
the governor and council for that
approval and we're able to us
essentially request those funds back
and and so we we use that calculation in
the same
with the county treasurer so if we have
as cheated
to them and if an owner and nona comes
back to us requesting those funds we can
take some of those funds back from those
counties
i'll probably ask tom for that tom can
i'm unable to see um because i'm sharing
so i'll come back to us so so your
question is
um the percentage that we achieved
right what percentage of the funds
you expect
to account let me let me go back okay
he's on the call he just needs to unmute
himself
yes
yes this is tom mcinnesville
the question is
uh it shows less county payments what
percentage
of the funds go to the county
it's really not a set percentage what
happens is the statute states as part of
the achievement after the achievement
process
at the end of three years any property
that we receive that hasn't had a claim
against it becomes that net amount
remitted
for that particular year so it's the
money that we received three years ago
but the law also allows so that's any
holder that has reported
property to the state of new hampshire
um and that holder is located out of
state
if the holder is located in state then
that same process that same is like a
mini calculation that is done for each
county based upon the amount of the that
was that was reported from the holders
in their county and then claims against
it
a further part of that calculation is
what happens is
in the during that whole fiscal year
we're also paying claims
and when we're planning claims for items
that we've had over three years
we go to front of the governor's council
and we have funds
sent back to us
from the general fund so we can pay
those claims for properties that we've
held over three years
so in this case we then net that against
so it's almost like we're borrowing it
to make that county the county claim
payment during the year but we're at the
end of the fiscal year what we're
ultimately going to send to the counties
is also reduced by any claim that was
paid as well but what they're getting
they're getting the net of the the
particular year like the the um
general fund the shipment calculation
example that monica has provided you
that would have been property that we
received in report year 2016.
so all of the monies that we received
from in-state holders in 2016
that money that was not claimed instead
of going to the general fund the statute
requires that it goes back to
the county from which that holder is
where that holder is located
it looks like it's about a 10 percent
range
is that but again but that's a one-year
snapshot so it can fluctuate greatly and
it can fluctuate greatly upon you know
claims that were made and then
particular reports that were that were
made as well and as you can imagine what
on the in-state um
on some of the ins on some of the uh
in-state holders a lot of them the
in-state banks so if we have a rather
large account that gets reported from
you know any particular county that
could really switch that one particular
year
um for that county
you know for how that calculation is
done but
yeah i i guess that would be i mean most
of the things that we do uh year-to-year
do seem to um
stay basically uh very consistent but i
say that would be a one-year snapshot so
you could never give it a percentage
it's just based upon the money that was
reported from those in in-state holders
in that particular year
let me ask you this could the county
get any one year more than what the
state gets
no that would be impossible because
the the uh what ends up happening is
that the vast majority of abandoned
property that is reported to any given
state
um
is typically from out of state holders
right
all of your national banks are
considered
national holders all of the securities
we receive those are all those are all
national holders so the in-state holder
portion is always going to be much
smaller
so of the in-state
money
would the county receive more money
than
what the state would get
that no that would never
that would never happen
the
the because there's always going to be
so if you look at any given year when
one when the treasurer showed those
slides we're averaging 17 million
dollars
um
17 to 20 million dollars that we receive
in any given year
upward to 75 to 80 percent of that is
always going to be reported from an out
of state holder so that's going to be
the driving force in that calculation is
that amount that was reported so the
amount that's ultimately achieved to the
general fund is always going to
foster past what was what is given to
any individual county all the counties
in total
that's all right we'll
um
representative romney has a question
thank you uh
i think i'm off speaking yep um
what happens uh you liquidated security
and uh and it's a cheated
back to the state uh what happens two
years from now that point and they come
someone comes to claim that money or
that those stocks let's say
do they get paid what the liquidation
uh
yes right tom yes yes but what happens
the statue requires that we have to hold
securities for at least one year
if we sold them if we sold any
securities
um prior to in the end of one year
the person would be entitled to whatever
the stock was trading at at present or
what we received as long as we go beyond
that one year and we do stand beyond
that we wait for that three year period
we always have a three year period we
are
we we we pay whatever we receive for the
security for the um
liquidation of that security and eating
dividends that were associated with that
uh during the period that we held it so
the person has made 100 whole from what
we received
okay but it doesn't it doesn't after
that date it doesn't that bad doesn't go
up and down it you you put it as long as
we don't as long as we don't sell before
a one-year period if we ever got into
the act of selling and you obviously
never want to do that but if we ever did
solo security uh within one year we
would be
um
until that pro when that person ever
came forward we would have this we would
have to provide them
whatever we received or what it's
presently trading for whichever is
greater
by the way for the new members i've been
doing this is my sixth budget
i never knew part of this went to the
county
in all these years so learn something
new every every time thank you
uh thank you mr chairman um my question
is when you liquidate stocks
is there any federal capital gains tax
owed
no
the the what what would happen again we
some we would sometimes have that
question
we're not paying any we're not paying
any um
well well two things are on there one
any payment that we
on the liquidation we are only receiving
what what they received so a person
typically may ask us do i have
do i have any tax liability on this
we can't give them that information
again that they would have to go back
what we received
they would have to make a determination
based upon what they initially purchased
for but it's nothing that we're involved
with
in the three-year period where we're
holding stock and a claim is made
um our custodian makes that payment so
if a person comes forward and says that
they are claiming shares that we're
holding they're given the right in that
three-year period when we still hold
them in sheer form
they're given that right to either claim
the stock in share form or have our
custodian liquidate them liquidate it
for them
if they choose the liquidation
our custodian does issue them at 1099
and there is a taxable event there but
we are not involved with that either
in the period there during the three
years that we hold it in sheer form or
after we hold after the liquidation
okay thank you
i don't see any is there anything else
you want to talk about the
yeah so at this point i think alternate
i turn uh i turn it over to tom for uh
to provide us more uh details of what um
some of the trends and initiatives that
might be coming
yes thank you um so what what we are
actually seeing um
with the trends i wanted to touch upon
the the just to give a backwater the
broad areas and monica touched upon it
for us the broad areas of that we're
receiving and we classify holders into
three general areas one is
um miscellaneous which is really a
catch-all for all our holders includes
all of the banks the transfer agents any
companies uh reporting um payroll checks
was any
most of our holders fall in that
miscellaneous category then we have the
government category and the insurance
category
uh miscellaneous and government they
have a reporting deadline that is
november 1st of each year
the insurance companies actually have a
separate
reporting deadline that's made for us
and that's typically they do report
other items um during that insurance
deadline but that is typically where
we're receiving the death benefits
insurance death benefits and that's
probably
the uh out of those three areas
again i'd say you know year to year
much of what we receive what we're
paying out seems to be very consistent
the one area where there continues to be
a little bit some growth is in those
death benefits and that's because the
states took an initiative
ten years ago and working with our
various audit companies
felt that the insurance companies
although they reported a great deal of
unclaimed property they were under
reporting unclaimed property for death
benefits where
their records actually showed the
insured was had passed away
but they were they were relying on a
provision that said if they didn't
actually have a claim against those
funds they didn't have to report it to
an individual state until three years
after the insured would have reached the
age of 99.
so those audits um
showed that that was not the proper way
to do it
it showed that the insurance companies
had that information they knew that they
had many of the insurers who had passed
away and that has greatly enhanced the
reporting and the insurance
death benefit area and i think that's so
that's probably one area that
remains strong and there could still
continue to be a little growth in that
particular area moving forward
uh generally just to give you a sense
also touched upon the five largest
reporting uh
properties that we receive by type
um
and they are the greatest uh amount of
property that we receive
uh during the last four years but all in
any particular year it's usually tied up
in a savings account
new hampshire has a dormancy period of
five years which is a very fair dormancy
period
uh five years at the end of a five year
period that's something more typically
more than a rainy day fund that someone
may have forgot about other states have
two years and three years dormancy
period for
for bank uh bank accounts and i think
that that um
can sometimes upset the account holder
because they really did have that set
aside for an emergency and and they're
not happy that it was moved after a
period of just three years
uh vendor checks are a
another large
uh property type to receive and that's a
vendor check it's it's typically would
you think of it as a check payable to
another business
but vendor checks a lot of um
when they code the property type a lot
of holders many entities actually
consider a vendor check payable to
anyone who's not one of their employees
one of their employees so that white
drives the vendor checks
because we receive so many securities we
do receive a great deal of dividends and
dividends
dividends actually drive the dormancy
period for securities
so many people that receive small
dividend checks um
you know they're almost considered a
nuisance especially in this day and age
when people don't go to the bank quite
as often as they use if they receive a
dollar 20 or a dollar 30 dividend check
they put it aside and they don't do
anything with it if they do that for
three years
the transfer agent then is supposed to
consider that account dormant
and not only transfer the dividends but
transfer the securities that produce the
dividends
so that's why there's so many dividends
that's why it's very important for
people if they do get those small checks
um
dividend checks to make sure they take
the time to cash them insurance death
benefits is up to number four i could
see that moving forward
and uh checking accounts again it's just
the same thing with the savings accounts
but again it's at that same what i
consider a very fair five-year dormancy
period
so i just wanted to give you that as a
background of the property types and the
general
type of entities that we receive
property from
so there are some new initiatives that
may result in
more property being reported
in the upcoming cycles
um
and some of it is there's
a
we're looking for we're looking to work
with the federal government for
resolutions for two major
areas
that have
incredible amounts of unclaimed property
but it's hard to get to a resolution
because the federal government doesn't
want to give up
the um the money that they're holding
and then
if
so would get to that when i talk about
those um the retirement council saving
bond but first
touch base upon um
electronic currencies bitcoin
cryptocurrencies that's becoming a very
big emerging issue
in unclaimed property and it it really
starts with
two schools of thought in the holder
community the holders of uh bitcoin and
cryptocurrency one school of thought
there is they want the states to take it
because now they've been in existence
long enough they have some very old
dormant accounts they don't want to hold
them and they would like to
find a resolution of a way of moving
that so they'd like the stakes to hold
it
you have other holders in that community
that are fighting and saying that
unclaimed property laws are not specific
enough
if they don't specifically have a
property type listed as
an electronic currency
they shouldn't be able to rely on their
catch-all provision which says any other
tangible property
should be reported if it meets that
dormancy period
on the flip side of that you have the
states also have two different schools
of thought out there
and one of them is some states say we'll
take cryptocurrency from you but you
have to convert it into u.s dollars
first
the other states say well
similar to stock it could be an
investment so it would probably be wrong
for us that to state that you needed to
convert that before you report it to us
because you should be able to
at least have it for a limited period of
time like the three years with the
shares of stock have a right to claim
what you actually on the property that
that had gone dormant
we we use a custodian for our securities
has seen this as an issue
and they have taken the initiative they
are in the position now
that the states that they provide those
custodial services for securities
not too far into 2021 they will be able
to provide that same
um
custodial services to actually take in
the cryptocurrencies in their in their
native form
so that's a good thing if we were to
pursue that avenue
also speaking with one of the audit
firms that we use today
they
informed me that
they would also be
[Music]
going to the states that they have
contracts with and
um seeing if they would like to join on
with some of the larger cryptocurrency
holders on examinations that would
the next big area is uh uncashed
retirement plant checks
uh
there is
estimates that there are
somewhere in the vicinity of a hundred
million dollars within the united states
on an annual basis
of
private retirement checks
uh private retirement um
accounts
their checks going uncached
the um
department of labor the united states
department of labor sees it as an issue
they want to work with the states doing
that
um but there is
there's always been
a
line drawn with the federal government
on
the uh private retirement accounts
saying that they have protection under
the erisa act and because they are
governed by the erisa act un state
unclaimed property laws do not
um
do not apply to them because of that
because of the
because of the the erisa act um in this
particular case you do have similar to
what there was elected they are
cryptocurrency holders some of the
holders say yeah we know that but can we
we'd like to do it on a volunteer basis
because voluntary basis because this is
the only way we're going to be able to
clean this up and they may the states
have
a higher potential of being able to
return the property to either to the to
the retiree or in many of these
instances i think it would be to the um
the ears of the uh of the retiree
and the us department of labor has
recognized this
they they've said that it's a problem
going back to the onset of erisa back in
so it's it's a you know
40 somewhat year problem that needs to
be resolved one of the things they're
thinking of or working towards is having
because the
all the small retirement um
small retirement
accounts or small retirement plans say
that they don't want to report to all 50
states so we're working the states are
working to see if we can have a
clearinghouse they could report to the
clearinghouse and then that
clearinghouse would report the money out
to the individual state of the lawson
address so that particular one seems to
have more traction that
via you know great resolution it would
be you know additional compliance on
property laws
um
a chance to get those untaxed checks
back to the family members of people
that didn't uh get to use them during
their lifetime or if they're still
living getting back to them
the next one united states savings bonds
is just a flip side of that this is
something that
the um
states have trying to been trying to
resolve with the united states treasury
for
30 somewhat uh 30-some odd years and it
it just it just moves back and forth and
it never gets resolved and it's all
based upon
the there's just so much money there
there this the
the estimates
the present estimates um
on the on the us
shave on
the fully matured
unredeemed united states savings the
bonds is 26 billion dollars
and of that 26 billion dollars
96 million dollars of it is estimated to
be
owed to
um
bond holders that when they purchase
them purchase them from a new hampshire
address
so what has happened that's moved back
and forth
the many of the states try to have a
legislative fix that where
they would recognize that the savings
bonds that were
um
registered to hold us within their state
we would have the right to
petition
the legislative the legislature passed
this five years ago saying and we joined
other states and saying that
we could advertise and then if we
couldn't find them having got that
information with the united states
department of treasury we would petition
the
court in in new hampshire they would
give us the right to go back to the
federal government and say okay now you
need to report these uh funds
so that several other states did the
same thing they have taken it um they
went into the courts they were in the
pro at the um
at the district court level the states
were successful the last um just last
year
earlier in the middle of last year
at the united states appeals court level
they found in favor of the united states
treasury so right now the only real fix
is um
hopeful fixed uh two um
bills that should be refiled in
the present
congressional session they were filed
live in the last session one in the
senate one in the house looking for some
modified fix to that
um
interestingly enough they had the filed
by a united states senator and a
congressman
both who formerly served as state
treasurers so that's where that stands
out that doesn't seem as promising in
the short term now as the uncashed
retirement plan
and then the fourth one i just touched
upon is the pre-need funeral accounts
we have uh many audits that we're doing
um
several audits that we're doing for com
with
one of our audit firms looking at the
national not the local female homes
looking at the national
um
uh providers of funeral services that
have these prenatal accounts and they've
been very reluctant to turn over funds
and and the the
the position is and we'd like to you
know have the article forward so we can
verify it is
in many of these instances they're
holding funds for people that actually
have already passed away and had their
final services
at another facility so that the funds
really should be released
to the benefit of the family
so those are some interesting things
there
um some of the other trends and
initiatives that we have
uh on our audit side is on
we're now looking some of the other
firms looking to do transfer agent audit
for us for securities
now securities audits in the past for
unclaimed property are always based at
the holder level
and then you look back to the holder
interaction with the transfer agent so
now we're actually going into the
transfer agent and reviewing the
transfer agent practices
and what that is showing is that there's
transfer agent practices that were
um
coding counts as undormant when they
were dormant and the companies never
knew that about that so we have seen
um
a beginning of um
an expansion of reporting of more
securities based upon those transfer
agent-based audits
um
we're also looking we so we in the the
audit sector
the the way it works um
for multi-state audits
the states have contracts with uh
several recognized firms we have them
without seven with um seven firms
ourselves
three of them are ones that have been in
this um
this particular area of unclaimed
property order for 20 years
or more
and they're very good they produce great
compliance
um
resulted in
hundreds of thousands if not uh you know
close to a million dollars of property
being transferred to new hampshire on an
annual basis
but they tend to look at
those traditional areas something like a
transfer agent or a large company
so we've also uh there's some new firms
that are offering these services and
they're looking
they're they're willing to take a chance
looking at some of these you know
emerging businesses and and online type
businesses
and those work out great there are some
short-term findings but often times
they're probably on finance with some of
those newer businesses that they're
looking at but it serves as an education
uh educational benefit
uh long term because when they go in
there and and they do this review with
these new companies
they may have not had any idea of what
they needed to do to be in compliance
with individual states unclaimed
property laws and now moving forward
they will
holder outreach is something we also
want to do to bring about more in-state
compliance and the way and what we do
with the holder outreach and we have a
team put in place
it has been delayed by uh first some
staffing issues um with with illnesses
and they are on the staff and then over
the last year just you know the room
different type of
work environment that we've been in but
we have a program ready to go and that's
going to be a
non-aggressive
holder outreach to in-state um
businesses to let them know that there
are on
unclaimed property requirements to
report
and this is how you would come back into
you come into compliance and you'd be
able to do that without any penalties or
interest so that that's something we're
ready to roll out as we emerge from the
um
present situation that we're in
the next two areas just want to touch
upon quite quickly are the um what we've
done is um
within the last year we've moved to
automation of claims um treasurer
mesopotamia touched upon us it works
great
i say it's user friendly but the example
i like to give is when we do outreach or
when we were doing that which before um
before the pandemic would you know
actually go out to a show and we'd deal
with people and
you know see if they had unclean
property whether it be
um
made new hampshire expo or something
like that
and you typically see
individuals in their
20s to 30s stop by the booth find out
that they have property and just want to
take down their information and tell
them they would be issuing them a claim
for them in the mail next week and they
just say oh no i'll do it online and
like well we didn't have that capability
and they'd walk away so i think this is
a great way to reach out to them and
and
more people are comfortable doing that
initiating the process online and
actually finishing it online
um and and it does expedite expedites
more timely payments
then we're moving into a further
initiative which is going to allow the
automation of some small claims
automatically
and it's going to be based upon
utilizing
a lexus nexus owner verification
software that has scoring that from the
information provided from the holder and
the information provided by the claimant
can come to a certain percentage match
that the state will set then those
payments will initiate automatically the
person would get an email once they put
that claim and they wouldn't even get
the claim form i have to provide any
documentation would say you're providing
us enough documentation you should be
receiving a check from the state in one
to two weeks
some of the states that have gone to
this um
have gone up to thresholds that are much
higher than we are comfortable with
we're looking to when we roll it out in
july of this year we're looking to start
off with claims 100 unless
um but there's so many small claims that
now when we issue them and it's
typically those 100 100
the people get the paper claim form they
see that they have to provide some
documentation and they say is it really
worth my time so i think we'll see a
much more a great deal more payments
being made off of those small claims
which would be great for us because we
end up
reissuing those same claims over and
over to the people and they don't send
them back
so thank you for listening to that and
if you have any questions i'd be happy
thank you thank you tom and
yeah i just wanted to uh you know just
to to wrap up the presentation um you
know the one thing i wanted to just
mention is
as you heard today uh you know this this
program is really not designed to
generate revenue uh it really is
designed to recover property and and to
return those funds to the proper owners
but um because of the way this this
program is um you know at the end of
this process uh the you know
unrestricted revenue has generated and
that's how the general fund is is benef
benefits from from from this but um
but again uh you know it's it's a very
unique program so we thought um that's
what we wanted to give you this overview
and spend a little more time so
hopefully this was helpful to you today
and with that uh we conclude our
presentation we'll be happy to answer
any any other questions that come the
committee may have okay we have a couple
of questions represented
jen
gian
thank you mr chairman um
my i have two two quick questions one is
um
uh regarding the vendor checks i i
didn't quite understand that i mean the
check is good for six months so does
that mean
if a vendor writes a check
and then you pass the six months the
check is no longer good but is it
because
there's still a liability owed
that if that person comes back and says
you know i never got my check
is that
yeah and it's the liability it's not the
still date on the check i it'd be that
that has that same dormancy period as
the other accounts we were talking about
would be a five-year dormancy period so
if
this the check was still it was still
dated it's not a valid check anymore but
it's still showing on the records of the
company as an outstanding liability and
that five-year period ends then if it
hasn't been
mitigated by a mediated through you know
another payment or another purchase if
it's still showing as that same
liability on the records then that
should be reported at the end of that
five-year period
okay that makes sense and then my second
question is
um what keeps an account active so in
other words if i mean the obvious thing
would be somebody makes a deposit or a
withdrawal or something but is it is it
enough for someone just to log in look
at their account and log out does that
keep it active
i my
the statute is not specific enough of
that but but the way that we have
treated that with wave and phone banks
for us we would say yes
if that is if that login and log out is
password protected and there is a
comfort level by that institution that
they know that that was the account
holder that actually logged in if it was
just someone saying that you know and
i'm not an expert on it but if they
could show that someone with that email
address logged on to the bank's website
that certainly wouldn't constitute that
activity but we have extended activity
that if
logging into your account even if you
didn't make a transaction um on a
um account
um viewings uh viewing format then we
would say that that would be contact
okay good and another another good thing
important thing to remember is that if
people have multiple accounts at banks
we also recognize what's called cross
referencing so if you had that rainy day
account
but you also had a checking account and
that checking account was active as long
as they send the notice out to you at
that that that address and let you know
at that time that
the con it says it's dormant but because
of your other account we would have
considered doing it then they wouldn't
have to do that because they they know
that the person still has
as cognizant of having a relationship
with that bank
okay great thank you
representative
thank you i have a question also for the
treasurer afterwards but i've been
checking your
your find your property
site and to my horror i discovered that
my father who has been dead for
for 18 years
on was apparently still considered an
active a member of the jua
payout
and is still listed there but
this is my problem he is listed as a
combination of himself and somebody
named la plant in uh
on milford
and milford has a zip code which is one
digit off of ours
on off of his
where he died on
what do you do
to report
what you think are mistakes because his
was a very unusual name
on
and there i was i give gold and i can't
find the other guy
and well typically i would i'd
if it was a portal like that it would be
someone that they may have been in
practice with but if you don't recognize
the name at all
then uh then
there could be and again that report was
not great in the format that we received
it was actually provided to us
by
the
a company that was working for the law
firm that did the final settlement the
good thing is we've had you know we're
paid a great number of claims out on
that report so that there is some good
information but if you
it's something like that and it and i'd
be the same answer that i'd give to any
more call if you contacted our office
spoke to um one of the claims
representatives or spoke directly to me
we'd do whatever we could to try to
differentiate you know to try to to see
if we could get that definitive event or
who that is
it's not as easy with an existing holder
but we would all i could certainly we
could reach back out to the yet the
company that did produce that actual
report to see if they could uh do some
more research on that but that is
something that we would we certainly do
for anyone that comes forward with that
question but would be more than happy to
do that for you as well
thank you i was wondering more whether
you could
put some kind of indicator on the web
page as to what you do if you think that
that you've got some of the information
but you don't have all of it
yeah
i i mean we could
typically if if it's people are having
difficulty with the you know it's always
you know reach out and we're for a small
office where
usually very easy to contact we and we
do try to call back it's a little bit
different now because we're not we do
have some we have some staff remote on
particular days so we don't have the
same number of people in answering the
phones on any given day but um we
certainly could do that and um i'll
certainly take that under advisement we
work with the the entity that provides
us with that internet service actually
provides that this nearly 30 states as
well now so it's probably something that
one of the other states has gone through
and i could i will look into that
you had also a question for the
treasurer
well i did if you want me to ask it at
the same time it's totally unrelated to
this unabanded property however
on we
on you issue a
bond issuance document
on each time you do a major bond
sale
and that is incredibly valuable for
someone who's trying to understand the
new hampshire economy
and i
can't figure out where to find it on
your website and i think the committee
would like to know
absolutely
i can certainly send a link
where we have it posted on the website
and we also have physical
we we have physical books in our office
we have plenty to distribute if there is
a way that we could um you know we could
um also facilitate that i mean we'll be
happy to give you some of the uh you
know the the physical books that we have
but certainly i will i will share the
link you know what i think um you know
uh chris shea and i
spoke about this before i think if if
the lba can figure out a way how to
distribute those books we'll be happy to
keep them out um but i will share that
link um so everyone has access to at
least the electronic copy right now
[Music]
um
representative
phillips or did you
pull your hand down i did remove my hand
sir i um thank you mr chair i had a
question on a follow-up about the
initiatives for the cryptocurrencies um
but i realize this is probably a really
tangential question i'm happy to just
email my question to the treasurer's
team and um try it
well my understanding is that
cryptocurrency accounts are password
protected and that the holder and the
rightful owner of the money the money is
solely indicated by whoever has the
right password
so i have a little con
you know
i guess spatial understanding of how
the account is deemed dormant and would
be in a
you know assigned to new hampshire
and then
you know if for some reason it sheets to
the state
and goes past the statutory period and
become state owned but we don't have the
password what is to protect that value
if someone who had the password
entered the password and took the money
and took the cryptocurrency away from us
i mean how to protect that
um furthermore um
what are other states doing is has
anyone been successful in trying to
redeem a cryptocurrency because my
understanding is that that's not
happening
it's again and that's why we it is truly
at its infancy stages for the states and
those holders and like i said there are
i guess with the password protection and
all of that of the various accounts they
would at least know if there hasn't been
any
activity in that account
so they could make that initial
uh determination as of being dormant
if it was transferred to our custodian
and the process they put in place it
wouldn't be held in that account any
longer it'd be i mean in a way it'll be
like the securities
when a security is transferred to us it
comes out of the name of john smith
and it is transferred during the time
that we hold it it's held in on nominee
name which is old man and co when a
person comes forward to claim it we then
go back and if they want to re-register
it we tell our custodian take those five
shares of company xyz
re-register it in the name of john smith
um
so so that so that process but again
like i this this is all new
with the
none of the states have taken in there's
no state that has taken in any
cryptocurrency as as of yet we have all
been approached by holders that would
like us to
our custodians have given us a method to
do that and now one of our audit
partners is going to
present us with um
with um some
some
firms that they think uh
ones that should be reviewed first and i
think at that point
and um so i'd like you know keep a
quarter i think i would be much
once that process starts with the audit
firm i'd be in a much better position to
give you an answer of how that process
may work when it is transferred to us
but i i don't have that information as
at this point yeah i mean i think that's
just the point is that i think this is
such a new and burgeoning area
um that no one really has the answers or
logistics because it hasn't been done
furthermore i mean
it is no insignificant amount of value
that's related to these currencies so i
can see why it's important for people to
try to investigate and to figure out
what would a potential
achievement look like but um
i just practically i
am very concerned i don't think it's
probably realistic right away
right but one of the things that when
you look at unclaimed property and it's
it's cut probably a
it's a dark way to look at it because
there's so much property that we receive
that is up that is for people that are
living
but we are we also receiving you know a
great deal of property in any given year
for people that have passed away
and so as these emerging i mean
cryptocurrency was you know
it's going on it's like a 10-year period
now so you probably do have some of
those they are probably holding funds
for some people that have actually
passed away and and if there is no way
to deal with that if there's we don't
put in a process some way to deal with
that then you go back to
the same thing that there was before the
way anyone came properly laws at all and
that would be
an undue enrichment to the holder that
is holding these funds so
again it's not going to be easy i don't
know where it's going to end up but it
is something that i think we really
should at least on the ground level see
where it goes
and at some point we'd probably have to
go back to the legislature before we did
anything to actually to move forward on
that
okay
i don't see any more questions
and it is
one minute after three
and i want to thank uh
moniker and tom for
dealing with this un
plain property issue
thank you very much and absolutely thank
you thank you for having us it was a
pleasure to be here
okay thank you thank you and for the
committee
tomorrow morning
uh we'll meet again most everybody will
be meeting virtually
but there will be a number of us that
will be at the
lob in
room 206
and we'll deal with public hearings on
seven bills
any questions before we break up
norm it's pat can you hang in there when
we everybody hangs up as well as alan
bernstein and uh and jennifer for a
minute sure okay thank you
i just want to remind you i've got an
appointment with janice tomorrow on noon
time
so
okay well
and thanks everybody for participating
all day long again
anyway